um
part host co-host sarah garvey but
before we even get started
you guys need to start liking sharing
and subscribing as we always say as
pearl always says if you've watched two
or more of our videos and you have not
subscribed then we have what else beef
beef beef okay beef if you have not
subscribed yet anyway today we are going
to be talking about cheating
something that people you know as close
to people's hearts we've all experienced
it you know and uh on the gray area
today it might get a little bit gray
we don't know how it's gonna turn out
but before we even get started pearl
over to you girl okay guys before we
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
turn on your notifications so you are
notified when we are live while you're
at it sign up for our memberships to be
a part of the chat the second half of
the show as you know we are on members
only for the second half on top of that
we also started a facebook page so that
is in the description of the video and
we're saving to get ish a camera i know
you guys are on the edge of your seats
you don't know what ish looks like
and if you want to find out send
donations so we can get ish a camera
you heard it right
there he is as a voice
okay guys so to start why doesn't
everyone go around say your name your
age your relationship status and where
you're from starting with you
how you doing my name is d also known as
d gully i'm 37 i'm single
south london
hi my name is lola rose i'm 28 i'm not
single i'm in a relationship um and i'm
from south london as well
hi i'm reems i'm 33 i am single and i'm
from west london
hey guys i'm nats i'm 32
and i'm from beckenham in south london
and i'm currently singlish
what a single issue can i have can i
have all the deeds
a situationship
is that how the kids do it these days
it's ridiculous
hi my name is kiana i'm 22 i'm single
and i'm from west london
all right
today
this one should be fiery i'm not gonna
like what should be firey i have some
statistics ladies and gents right um
there is a website called hackspirit.com
it's a relationship
website and they do some cop they do
some correlation on cheating okay so
they've put together all of these stats
from all these different
um websites and they've come up with
some statistics now i'm going to read
you some i'm going to see what you guys
are going to say
uh
what do the numbers say is what it says
overall numbers on infidelity are
alarmingly high
marriage and divorce concludes that a
mind-blowing
70
of married americans cheat at least once
in their marriage
more reliable numbers from the eu
general social survey point to lower
statistics for individ infidelity but
they are still worrisomely high
70 percent
of married people
cheat in their relationship
what do you think about that
wow is it that because i the ones i
heard was 25 and 28 percent so that's
that's a lot higher than i was expecting
but that might be a more recent one i
think yeah it's like 20 21. oh wow and
um i think they are counting not just
sexual
intercourse that's what i was wondering
yeah because the first question is what
is cheating they're not counting just
sexual interest it's some kind of
cheating
what do we think about 70 ladies and
gents that is high um but i think it it
makes sense in a bit because you're
always like
being with one person especially in
marriage it's like for life and then
you kind of get curious
there's temptation everywhere you can't
hide it so it kind of is a bit realistic
just that people would
fall for the temptation because not
everybody has that self-control
yeah i think i'm a little i was a little
bit surprised with that number to be
fair um but i do think what it shows is
that a lot of people are in unhappy
marriages and just aren't vocalizing it
sad times
that's a big thing as well people not
being honest with themselves let alone
the person that they're getting married
to
so i have a question have you guys ever
cheated
nope
yep
yeah
yep
yeah yeah
reluctantly she says
i've never cheated no have you ever
cheated
that's the most girls we've ever had say
yes to that yeah
girls never admit it they always say
yeah i know
because
why i said yes as well because
cheating's not just sexual that's what i
was going to ask it's not just sexual so
the cheating that i did
i knew what i was doing i knew talking
to the person that i was talking to and
what
it was gonna
you know lead to
but didn't
i just know i was just winding up
it's an emotion so where what happened
so you're in a relationship with one guy
yeah and then who is the second guy a
friend that my partner at the time
didn't lie so it was a i was a guy did
he put you in the friend zone or did you
put him in the friend zone i put him in
the friends so and you never saw him
that way no no you did see him that way
i didn't see him that way i just knew
that i was angry
and i wanted to
what could i do to hurt this man that's
hurt me right now i know i might have a
conversation
to this guy about
this guy so you were flirting with the
other guy or did you hook up with him i
wasn't really i wasn't really flirting
but i was flirting in that i knew what
he wanted but i just knew it wasn't
going to be that so doing that would you
say men and women can't be friends
they can be friends
i think they can be friends
i wasn't trying to be like i said it was
on me i knew what i was doing he
probably thought okay she's coming to me
to talk about a situation oh maybe this
is the time i know it wasn't the time i
just knew okay
what would hurt him even though i wasn't
telling him what i was doing
i suppose in my mind i knew he didn't
want me to do this so i'm doing it did
you physically cheat ever no so it was
like but you would agree that like
attention seeking and flirting that's
cheating
100 where you caught
i told him
[Music]
because you did it so he would know so i
was like yeah do you know what
i spoke to x y and z
so hold on because forty seven point
eight percent of cheating females and
thirty nine percent of cheating males
were caught by their significant other
wait did you say more women were caught
um
wow more women were caught than men were
caught really
that's interesting because most people i
talk to say the opposite that they think
women get away with it more yeah
i believe that
i don't know flirting has cheated
definitely so you don't count flirting
as cheating because i think we all kind
of naturally flirt
that's how i won't say naturally flat
you can be
you can be a naturally flirtatious
person you can do it innocently
i don't believe there's innocence behind
flying i feel like you know what you're
doing you know if you say something this
way or if you flick your head that way
if you look a man in his eye too long
you know i feel like
people know what they're doing it's just
you flat with every and everyone or you
just
no i think when it comes to like the
whole flirting thing i think it's down
to the individual and how your partner
perceives your flirting obviously
there's like higher levels of being
disrespectful
flame but i think like if you're a
character like charismatic person and
your personality naturally draws people
in then it may be perceived as you
flirty okay but then that's just you
because i could say that i can
get along or let's say vibe with
everybody but i'm not going to be
like
concrete what flirting is with everybody
i understand that people can see that as
as are you you're talking to a man for
too long or whatever or whatever
but
flattening is flat and still do you know
what i mean that just down to that
person and jealousy behind
your actions or behind that situation
you look like you wanted something to
say something over there bro 100
sorry it was the moment when you touched
on being a woman and being charismatic
and that you
attempted to kind of link
charisma
which can be perfectly harmless
which isn't necessarily harmless
it's the perspective it's all about how
the others see it it's not necessarily
what you in your mind like if naturally
like she said if you get on with people
it you know that can be perceived by
your partner who if they have certain
insecurities if they're not quite
charismatic themselves they may see it
as oh she's talking too long or she's
laughing a little bit too much or
whatever but if that's your natural
personality and then that's just what it
is well i think there's a line right
like there's sometimes where the guy can
be a little bit controlling and he's
like who are you talking to all of the
time but i just i think as women we know
when we're flirting and we know when
we're not flirting and a lot of times
girls will flirt and pretend like
they're doing nothing when they're not
yes you're laughing
so they're like i don't know what you're
talking about and you're like
your arms were around him diane
that's different
so you said you ladies have cheated have
you been cheated on
yeah yeah can i add a point can i add a
new dynamic we're also assuming that
everyone is in a heterosexual
relationship
which i am not so i am dating a woman so
i'm bisexual i've been cheated on by a
man
i've you know so when you add that
dynamic as well i think it's important
to realize that when we're saying oh
well women do this and men do this not
everyone is straight
so we can't just assume that based on a
gender role that is made by society that
that's going to base whether the
cheating has occurred or not or how we
should look at is cheating not cheating
no cheating is cheating but we're
from the conversation that's being had
people are saying oh well
women would know when it's this men
would know when it's that men might you
know
do you not think men and women are
different of course we're different
we're made differently yeah so that's
what we're talking about so we're saying
the dynamic yeah yeah yeah because we're
saying like men do this women do this
because we're different 100
but what about in a relationship where
both this woman and one of them cheats
okay do you think just actually i have a
question i wonder if when i see um
same-sex relationships i find that
there's still a masculine and a feminine
even in that agreement where even one of
the girls is a little bit more masculine
and one's a bit more feminine that's
cool so it's like almost you
have a similar dynamic in a way
i'd imagine it's still different because
they're still women
or men but i've just noticed there's
still a little bit
of the polarity 100
so you've
been cheated on i have
okay did you did you find out all you
told
so actually the person that cheated on
me was we were in a very long-term
relationship so in all we were together
nearly seven years
um and he had cheated at the very
beginning of the relationship which made
it easier to forgive because it was it
was early and as was mentioned before it
depends sometimes on the level of which
that cheating was so that was like he
went on holiday a little holiday fling
came back admitted it straight away so
we were able to move past that
in a more progressive way that was the
first mistake
that yes you never admit
it
oh okay oh that was oh that's
good i mean cheating was the first
mistake
and then when that occurred again it was
years later
and more serious but for me
i more look at why people do things that
they do because the act of cheating
itself hurts but for me it's more the
lies and the deception around it so the
first time where he openly admitted as
soon as he got off the flight this
happened we could move past it but the
second time i had to find out
and the continuous lies is the issue was
it um was it a one-time thing or was it
like a whole side check
it was like a whole side check but it
was more emotionally based so for me
cheating is also about when you have an
emotional connection with someone so
flirting is one thing everybody likes
attention we're all human but you like
attention when you go beyond that
boundary you have to set boundaries with
yourself i set boundaries with myself
even when i'm single so if i feel like
someone's stepping over a boundary of
what i find appropriate if i don't like
them in that way i'm like okay it's not
that so just because i'm single doesn't
mean i'm gonna allow someone to overtake
the boundary of what then is leading
them on almost so the emotional side of
it is sometimes more painful than the
physical act so don't you think like men
and women cheat differently don't you
think women cheat emotionally and men
cheat physically i i do believe that
sometimes sometimes but you can't it's
not linear
sorry
because i think
especially nowadays i think this
narrative of old women just are cheating
because they want somebody like
emotionally i think that's like back in
the day i think now you'll find a lot of
women
that will cheat because maybe they're
not satisfied well it doesn't mean no it
doesn't necessarily mean they're
cheating emotionally but women cheat uh
men cheat down
so like have you ever like have you ever
said
have you ever um like i always i say
this a lot i it was the worst day ever
when i realized i had to worry about
ugly girls too
because because yeah because
because
men will well i've had guys say to me oh
she was better than my hand
right so so guys will cheat with
anything but a woman if she's cheating
like
it might be physical but the guy has
something that hurts the one doesn't
that the other one does it
where a guy could just like maybe she
came on to him really strong and they
just you know
yeah and what's my saying men can have
sex with a hole in the wall and not okay
who's on the other side yeah
they can
so it's like that's why i said men cheat
physically yeah women cheat emotionally
yeah yeah i think so i think for women
to even
i don't think a lot of women can just
cheat like have sex with the sake of it
either like they they have to have some
sort of emotional attack connection or
something to the person that haven't
said always they're not gonna enjoy the
sex and then what's the point if you've
got a relationship
and then you're gonna go out and cheat
anyway and then it's like well that was
a waste of time well i think women when
they're they're cheating they're
planning on leaving you yeah
and they're and they're looking for
their next guy
where where men are just like yeah she
was there
like they because men can hate a girl
and still have sex with her women it's
not the same yeah exactly
that's so familiar
that's a very emphatic line right there
you know what's that just the fact that
um
the fact that for women it's not the
same
that's important yes it's like if you
if you accept the fact that once a woman
starts cheating she's on her way out the
door yes yeah then
then you can't also believe well not i'm
not saying anybody here does believe
this but i'm aware of a strong belief
among some women that
being promiscuous is
the same
absolutely no difference
against men doing the same thing
and that women should be able to sleep
with who they want without any feeling
of repercussion or and it's like well if
you believe that
because essentially what you're
basically saying is right for a woman is
cheating because she's on her way out
the door yeah
then it doesn't then it's not natural to
a woman to stay in a relationship happy
but just sleeping with someone else
every saturday
that's not that's not natural that
that's not
science
i think it's scientific sorry going well
women men and women sleeping around is
different because um if a girl has is a
virgin when she gets married she has an
80 chance of a happy marriage if she
sleeps with more than five people it
drops down to 25
where men um they're actually their
marital happiness goes up around seven
or eight partners
like they're more happy than two or
three do you ladies know what peer
bonding is
go on
so pair bonding basically
it's they're
it's basically your ability i know
they actually don't use this term
anymore because it's not the correct
term i guess
but
what they're talking about is women's
ability to bond so the more people she's
been with the more she compares um to
previous partners because we're
naturally hypergamous and we want to get
the best guy that we can and so if let's
say you know someone has sex with 30
people what are the odds that the person
she marries is the best that she's gonna
get probably slim especially because men
sleep down so a lot of times girls that
are like fours fives and sixes think
they're eight nines and tens because
they're sleeping with eight nines and
tens but those guys would never be seen
in daylight with you yeah they would
they would
so so a lot of so that's why that's the
issue that comes with sleeping around is
that
like women think they're higher than
they are and then when they realize that
these guys don't want to commit to me
and they have to get something long-term
then they're on they're not satisfied
with the guy that's actually on their
level
the more the more guys that a woman has
sex with
the the harder she finds it
to actually settle down with that one
guy likes like pearl said you're you're
thinking about that there's
within that time there's been that one
guy
there's been that one guy
okay and so you're thinking about him
like i said there was a netflix show on
last year called sex life i don't know
if you guys saw it where there was a
woman on there who had the perfect life
she had the perfect life perfect husband
perfect life
but she kept thinking about this one guy
right that she was you know attracted to
in her 20s and she basically destroyed
her marriage for this guy
and
um
it happens women can't get that one guy
out of the head and they destroy their
relationships for him
and you know what i can agree with that
this is why multiple dating is dangerous
for women at least
i don't multiple date but i understand
the concept why women do because when
you look at what you were saying paul in
the sense of you know we
we kind of if we have the option out of
say 10 men then we're gonna pick the
best one that we feel is best suited to
us but i think it's a dangerous place to
put yourself in because we do sleep
emotion that we our emotions are there
when we sleep with somebody so i
i suppose if you're dating and you
decide that you're not going to sleep
with with any of the people that you're
dating
that's a bit i don't know a little bit
strange to me because if i'm dating you
it's because i'm sexually attracted to
you so that means i'm now going to have
to really really control myself not to
sleep with you i would rather date one
person at a time so that if i do end up
sleeping with you there's an emotional
attachment there and i don't have to be
thinking oh my god i've made emotional
sexual attractions to multiple men and
then i'm sitting thinking oh my god
which one's better than the other no
so then saying that now so then
acknowledging that do you think that
men and women are wired differently
biologically do you think men are
actually wired to be able to have
multiple women more so than women are
wired to have multiple men and the
reason why i say that there's actually a
book there's a book called out of eden
by a guy called david barash and in that
book he states that
previous to the western
ideal of one man one woman type
relationship
most uh societies were living in some
kind of polygamous or polignous type
relationship prior to that and what
happened is with the coming of these
quote-unquote western ideals um
people kept on saying okay well one man
one woman whereas what we can see when
it comes to one man one woman you've got
70 of people in marriages
at least cheating so it's like are we
actually wired differently well i think
we are i'm sorry um eight thousand years
ago seventeen women reproduced for one
man
you say how long ago eight thousand
years ago it's not that long oh my god
yeah if you look at like if you yeah if
you look at it historically yeah like if
you want to look at the any so
so biological drivers is something and
science we are biologically different
and we have different biological drivers
that determine what our purpose is
in that sex category is different to
gender so
society has made
gender roles and gender constructs
that's not scientific so you're assigned
to sex at birth so you're male or female
and then okay
is this my personal
thing so if you're assigned a sex you're
male or female but then you're then
boy girl so you've got a male gender
role or a female gender role that
society then
creates to say that
your role as a man traditionally
speaking is to be the provider and the
woman is to be you know taking care of
the household and they're more emotional
that's obviously a construct that we've
grown up with
from from birth you know in this western
front
yeah exactly so but however
scientifically as you just said
does that mean that we weren't made here
to reproduce
when you say you are assigned a gender
at birth no no not a signed agenda sorry
a sex it's a different thing all right
so you're a man or a woman at birth yeah
science so you're a man or a woman
yeah so
you're male or female
which one man woman may not be
talking about
okay so we're we're male and female okay
but from the beginning of
human
conception males have been males and
females have been females males can't be
male as males can't be females and
females can't be males how and but with
those assigned with with those roles
yeah comes
um
other roles
right like like provider like protector
the biology of the person that we call
male is the same biology of the person
that we're talking about right now who
used to breed with 17 women 8 000 years
i'm agreeing with you yeah right but so
when you say so so what's the
so are you are you saying that a female
or a
woman what
that confuses me nowadays
can now assume that same role in having
um in now having 17 people no i was
agreeing with what you were saying that
there's a difference between why it
might be that men would go to have
multiple partners because scientific i
was agreeing with you not just right
it's very like i don't know it just is a
bit confusing so question would you guys
um if you were
a guy that had everything you wanted
right and would provide you every your
dream guy
would you overlook cheating and kind of
make it known that as long as he's not
making babies with anyone there's no
stds no one really finds out about it
that's cool you're not gonna leave
you're you're his ride or die i know you
said you could overlook cheating or you
seem to
not overlooked there's a difference
between overlookers in like just not be
bothered and look at why they did it
what did you contribute to how it got
there as someone mentioned before if
they're in an unhappy relationship if
you're unhappy it's because i've
contributed towards your unhappiness so
i would also take accountability into
why my partner cheated on me and look at
what i could do differently to make sure
that they're happy in that relationship
and move forward because you have to
take account of belief
what if it's nothing to do with you
then in which case that's that then that
they need to take up full accountability
and then you could end that relationship
so
i always look into why people do what
they do how did i contribute towards
that not just putting the blame on that
person sometimes it is literally just
all them they went out they got pissed
they slept with someone or did whatever
that's nothing to do with you that as
you said it's just a one-time situation
in other cases if there's unhappiness
involved is there a dynamic where they
don't feel comfortable to speak to you
you're not communicating effectively the
second time that my ex had cheated on me
i did take some accountability for the
fact that i was overly busy i was
working full-time doing a night school
degree training to be in team gb and
doing athletics i had no time for him so
when i did come home i wasn't giving him
enough time of day for him to feel happy
where their warning sounds
yeah so for uh warning signs it was all
very sudden so he'd mentioned you know
dissatisfaction with the fact that i
didn't make enough time i attempted to
create more time and i tried but it was
already too late so i think he expressed
that once he'd already gone too far but
he didn't want to tell me he was
cheating but i noticed it was it was
blatantly obvious because i i think
people see signs
and they ignore themselves yeah
there's always signs i saw the signs and
i asked and he denied it so that's where
the betrayal where it's like why didn't
you just say because i gave you the
opportunity to let me know so we can
move forward but the lying and then it
all
spirals just jumping bro i'm sorry i'm
not trying to get muted
i need to talk up i'm not going
for a reason
yeah can i ask you a question please do
is there anything about you in terms of
how i might read your character and how
you come across is there anything
different about you now that you're in
same-sex relationships
that i would notice than from when you
were not in same-sex relationships i
think i'm more of a liberalist so
personally for me i've always known that
i like girls and boys since i was a
child it's never bothered me in my
earlier years i dated men for my own
reasons you know family constructs etc i
am more liberal as individuals so i do
see things
slightly differently to others may um
but yeah that would be the only thing
the reason why i ask it is because i
think sometimes yeah
i think it's all well and good like when
somebody's being dishonest with us we
say you know
they had the opportunity but
sometimes we might just be hard to talk
to and we don't realize 100 percent our
partner we are not easy to talk to we
don't realize it speaking
sorry bro we're not easy to talk to we
don't realize it
and so that's why it makes it hard for
people to come to us and be like all
cars on the table digital scanner yep
then sorry go on dude there might have
been a thing because i know it's one
thing you mentioned earlier but you said
you know what when you first got
together
and he cheated he came to you and said
listen this is what the deal is
however when this happened later on in a
relationship it wasn't so forthcoming
yep so
don't you think people should like
i don't know it might it might seem a
bit crazy but i don't think people
should when getting into a relationship
to say listen okay if we're getting like
really serious
like and we want to be with each other
for this prolonged period of time should
we come up with some kind of
contract and say listen
you know pound you you know me already
pal you know me in this contract like do
do i get like a pass like every 12
months or something you know like ask
for a pass because you know maybe at
some point in time i may want to do
something no
i'm straight
so if you guys had everything you wanted
you wouldn't accept cheating no you
would what about you too
no listen no i wouldn't accept you no
you know why i say that because i've
been cheated on did you say
i did so you did it
no no but that's what's made this was
years ago okay that's what's made me and
i've been cheating on twice did you did
you say the second time never never and
and never would i because for me how i
look at it once you've
done that you will come you will do it
you will do it it's within you you
cannot stop no more like you've you've
got the taste of it now like
i do agree with you on some level but
did you know that um a hundred percent
of women want twenty percent of men
twenty percent so the reason that women
hate men is because we're all sleeping
with the same ones
wow yeah so if you ask women to list
like what they want in a guy so for
example yeah for example something i
hear a lot is women want someone over
six foot oh yeah
i'm not six foot that's if if a girl
requires over six foot that's 15 percent
of men yeah or or say a lot of girls
will have an income requirement well i
find women kind of do this he has to be
like this he has to do this he has to
and it's like you look at the partner
they end up with
nothing like that well but then a lot of
times they cheat on him
because yeah and that's what i'm saying
it's not who they wanted it's not their
first choice
and that's it's yeah it's it's not their
first choice because they've maybe slept
with their first choice but he would
never be seen with her in public
that's why hypergame is a thing because
when they feel like they found that guy
they'll go for that guy they might not
have him now right but if they find him
you better know that she's gonna try and
shoot her shot with that guy
but that's what i was saying though why
like something he said earlier on today
there was this thing where he was
talking about tradition and backing it
in
it's like
agree or not agree once upon a time
some most a portion of whatever the
weather some women would rather have
been the side piece to the aristocrat or
the king than to be the loyal wife of
the shoemaker
actually a question would you rather see
a guy you really really like once every
two weeks
or see a guy you kind of like twice a
week no give me once every two weeks
yeah exactly exactly you're picking side
chick that's side chick
no that's no i'm serious that's side
chick time
because i'm not okay i'm not you know
why because i've been in a long-term
relationship i have not needed to see
you all the time that's just how well
which is fine once out of those two if i
had to have somebody constantly there
just because we're together no but i'm
saying that's that's side check like
once every two weeks is is a side check
yeah the main shake is getting you're
getting he's getting she's getting time
yeah how how often how often are you
gonna
at least what two
twice a week two three times a week at
least that's about to pick out the two
i'm not picking someone i don't i'm just
not gonna settle but but if i had to
pick but
this is why fifty percent of women over
are this is why fifty percent of women
are single and childless over thirty
yeah and that's very true and because
because it's like it's because it's like
the idea of we'll we're never gonna
settle yeah yeah yeah and it it's
unfortunate because the least happy
group of women is 45 they're 45 they
make over 50 thousand dollars a year and
they have no family or kids yeah
and now it's the man that i
your standard is like stay in your lane
like i don't think it's an issue i think
a lot of the times like you said we have
this fantasy of yeah he has to be six
foot he has to have this all she has to
be
so toned and she has to have her be
career driven and all this and that she
has to be a good mother and all these
care about your career right now
makes you feel good
yeah that's true
actually on that you're saying that i
don't think men would i don't know would
men really want a woman that's just
willing to just kind of ride their coat
out and just be there for them to be in
there i think yeah with the program yeah
let's let's get with our program we know
exactly what's going on yeah and if
you're a man who's actually doing stuff
and you've got you've got stuff to do
you you've got meetings you've got you
know i mean you've got a life you want
to know that things can be scheduled in
you don't want to be like oh i don't
know when i'm going to see the woman
that i want to see yeah i don't i don't
want to be like that i want to know when
i'm going to see them what's that
availability yeah you want a woman who's
available can i ask a question then so
based on that say you had um a partner
and she was the one who was
boss in it and she had to schedule you
and you both of you are equally doing
your career and etc does that then put
you off because what i've found
okay because interesting but in both my
long-term previous relationships one
with a male and one with a female i've
been
they you know things have ended because
they haven't been keeping up with me in
what i'm doing because they haven't came
up with you yeah and i found that with
men i find it difficult to
be with men because of how much i do
that they that is somewhat maybe
intimidating or does there you go
okay so this word intimidating needs to
get shot down
explain to me because men when it comes
to this men are not intimidated by women
men
have a certain way in which they work
okay and women
they they go into this
workplace and they feel like
okay well i'm in this workplace i'm
doing well for myself and
the guy may not be doing that
he's not intimidated by that what he
doesn't want is a woman who is going to
give him a schedule
it's it's it he doesn't want to because
it's a very masculine thing do you think
guys do not want masculine women all
right well babe i can fit you in now
this is my schedule here we go this is
when we're going to spend time together
no man wants that interesting like i
think
i think most men would prefer it's like
um i'm picking you up at this time and
then they just say yeah yeah okay
exactly yeah
you don't want to say all right babe
i'll pick you up at seven tonight is
that okay is that what are you the man
what's going on here i'll tell you what
time and there's a man and maybe maybe
not you personally because obviously
it's not like we know each other like
that personally but yeah
for the women who approach relationships
with this mindset that well i need a man
who kind of needs to be on my type of
time because i've got to go on and i got
this and that guy and i need to be on my
time i feel like there's a man out there
for every woman who says that there's a
man out there that if you a man out
there of a certain calabar that if you
were with him you'd respect the program
still right i feel like because you
can't get him yeah you get it it's like
i can't get him surrounding him
so if rather than focus on where i can't
get him
i'm just gonna work with you i'm working
with now and you don't gotta get with my
program and eventually you see that what
that does that breeds
for a woman if a woman feels like she's
the man in the relationship she doesn't
respect her
resentment yeah she doesn't respect him
okay and so what happens is she's gonna
cheat on him eventually because she sees
him as somebody who's weak that's what
happened to me yes there you go yeah
would you say though that there are
because obviously i understand that for
me how i look at it real men don't get
intimidated that's how i was
there are there are men out there in
certain pools because there are
different pools like that's how women
will complain and say oh my gosh but i
can't find this man but i'm like you're
still fishing in the same pool that you
found the man you didn't like
um so fair enough there are men in those
pools that kind of aren't on that level
get with a woman who is maybe doing
something and then kind of maybe try and
uh
you're always doing this bring her down
but it's not that oh
he's upset with what she's doing he's
intimidated by the fact that she's more
masculine right but she can't get a guy
on her level that's a real problem
it's not just the it's not sometimes
it's the most if if a girl
if a girl
guy a or guy b yeah guy a
same guy he makes your amount of money
or higher yeah guy b makes less than you
yeah everyone's picking guy a if she has
the if she has the option she's gonna
take it what if she's still swimming in
the fishing in the same pool that's what
there's some women that don't go out
their own halls or their own area and
they're kind of and i'm like what are
you doing i mean
i think they like control sometimes they
don't want a guy above them because they
they'd rather just be in control but
they end up hating that guy right they
end up
they're like ball busters
i went on a date once with a woman who
was very highly successful very high
paid job you know um what's she doing
six figures she was a banker okay um
six figures
i can tell you that how do you know
because you know you get
um but you know i actually had to ask
her on a date like
because she was she was talking about
all the stuff that she has and what she
does and i said what do you need a man
for
like what do you what do you want one
for and she was like oh you know
companionship and blah blah and in my
head i was like i had a [ __ ] dog
i'm not a dog like what do you mean
companionship
and that's when i realized oh do you
know what's happened and the thing is
it's no fault of her own you see it's
just because she's gone into a world
where she has to she's had to be a
certain way and she's gone into this
this world and i'm just like yo i'm not
really and they said it's not
intimidation it's me realizing what's
the long-term effects of getting with
somebody that's going to be like this
what is it going to look like down the
road i ain't trying to have no woman
come home and be down on that to me
acting like i'm an employee it's not
happening
and what percent of girls like that are
really okay with the guy being in charge
of the household finances even though
she makes more than him
but one this is the question
because i kind of think okay as you were
saying that triggered me a little bit
because in my head i'm thinking
right what is it that men want because
we hear a lot of our women are gold
diggers women just want men for their
finances what they can provide this and
that right
but then in the same breath you're
saying you don't want to be looked at as
you're a dog like she if she's too busy
what do you need gold digging is a
lifestyle why can't she just want you to
just be to to be you and be available
and equally and for you are it's amazing
am i an employee well hold on but she
could just want you rather than needing
you what do you want women to need them
when you say that guys put you in the
for fun category right when you say i
don't i don't want a man i say um i
don't need a man i want a man like
because they're like well i don't want
to get involved with this yeah like that
that screams to men for fun recreational
use only that's right can i add
something as well to that it also kind
of puts the if you don't need him and
you essentially want him he's
discardable yeah and that means you
technically have no loyalty to him
that's correct and men value loyalty at
a rate that women may never understand
can i counteract that
um
you could want something and be loyal to
what you want because at the end of the
day if i don't want you i'm not choosing
you a lot of the time women have the
choice really have the choice because
you i can have a plethora of men that
want me but i
i'm the one that really has the last
decision
i'm gonna choose you and if i choose you
i choose to put my time my energy my
efforts into you regardless of what's
going on in my outside world so that's
why i say for me i would rather want the
man than need them
any woman that says she doesn't need a
man kevin samuels had a saying
buy a dog and die alone
[Laughter]
but also does the husband not also need
his wife i think we're looking at it
maybe on this list
not necessarily
i'm just wondering if it's for me i find
interdependency rather than dependency
to be if that's me personally i can only
speak my own truth for me i find
interdependency in a relationship
important so you provide this i provide
that we balance each other out it does
it that could also mean that if example
people think a lot about finance if for
example
my partner loses their job maybe at that
point i will put in more finances at
that point to support the relationship
and
so on and so forth to understand so for
me there's a level of more balance and
this scales
why why oh that's an interesting concept
explain why because if a man marries you
okay
you are taking on
the house his children
and his life and you now have the power
unfortunately as a woman to divorce him
leave him with no house no children and
broke
you have that power as a woman to do
that no and a lot of the time women do
do that okay so like i said a man has a
lot more to lose than a woman does a
woman can do all the bad behavior that
she wants to in a marriage and still end
up with money in her pocket and children
and a house
and cars
and
difficulties
with the money
with the money
you can get rid of the stretch marks and
get a bbl yeah
i'm saying what i'm trying to say is you
you women end up with the better end of
the deal if the relationship goes south
like um in in the u.s it's especially
bad here you're entitled per kid it's 13
or the first kid it's three or title to
13 of his income
which to me it's like i don't understand
why can't you get a sick you shouldn't
need that person you should want them
you should value them but what they've
what and that's it and that's a good
function and that's a good single person
mindset
that's a single person mindset you like
if you're going to be with someone for
50 years you don't think you're going to
need them
but that's that's like
a lot of times modern women it's it's
fear if it doesn't work out what's going
to happen because i've never seen a
relationship work out
see the thing is okay let me get a
little bit personal so i was in a
relationship for 15 years with my
children's father and our relationship
wasn't this
i played my role and i played my
position and i supported him i valued
him for what he was in the household i
gave everything when it came to a point
where
my children are getting older did you
get married um no we did not and that
was a bit of a thing because at the
beginning i didn't believe in marriage
and i kind of really kind of don't
because so you're the one who didn't
want to get married at the beginning
then say 10 years down the line i didn't
want to get married
oh a woman changing
[Laughter]
that was my choice also because i'd have
to ring easily at this point but my
point in saying that right very
confidently my point is saying that is
the fact that um the relationship i
played my lane up i was in i played my
position i supported him when i got to a
point where like i said my children were
getting older and i really wanted to
discover who i was as a person
just as much as he was talented and he
knew what his skill was and he knew what
he wanted to do in this world and the
legacy he wanted to leave behind i was
steadily behind him trying to figure out
who am i what am i doing i know i have
my children they're a great legacy but i
also i'm i'm an individual who has my
own purpose in life when i got to a
point where i wanted to discover that
and i really ventured out into it um i
became a children's book author i found
that it really changed the dynamics in
our relationship hugely to a point where
i felt he did feel insecure he did feel
like i didn't need him anymore and all
of it did you act like that
did you act like you didn't need him
anymore no i didn't what i what i
started to notice is that the energy
that i put into him when he was pursuing
all his goals for the past 10 15 years
that was not reciprocated and that's
where my frustration was and so why did
you leave was that be why yeah
it really ultimately was because i felt
like i spent my whole life
supporting your dreams
you were you were with a man for 15
years with children
and you decided to leave because
it wasn't okay there's a multitude of
things that obviously go into it 15
years a lot of baggage right there's
other things that i wouldn't have to
look at it just a lot of time and effort
it was a lot of time and effort and i'll
never i'll never take it back i learned
some real life lessons from that
relationship honestly but it also taught
me that whoever i now get with has to
understand the type of industry and what
i'm doing they have to be within my
world so
what do you think it's going to look
like for you now in the dating market as
a single woman with three children try
to [ __ ] and and
you right you you you've left a you left
the man that committed to you you had
three three of your children you've left
him you're now on a dating market with
three children
what do you think it's gonna look like
for you on the daily market the desert
it's the desert what do you think is
better out here the desert they're liars
so
but that's where i think that
is crazy because i think because i i
understand i've been in a long-term
relationship i've come out of it it
didn't work um and you do look at the
time and i think that was the biggest
frustration the time the effort the
years the just everything um but then
it's do you then stay with somebody
and just settle down and just be that
person yes
okay
yeah that's why then 70 percent of
people cheating you know duties
duty is more important than happiness
it's not about you like once you have a
family it's not about you anymore you
you come second to the family and i can
respect that i can to an extent yeah
ultimately
we are all individuals of our own
purpose in life one at a time one at a
time
to save
that dog and dialogue if your children
aren't unhappy
or your house isn't happy
do you stay together because it's your
duty and have unhappy kids that have to
deal with uh a
trauma when they're older than their
parents
well it's traumatic to have the dad out
of the home
you put your kid at every statistical
disadvantage if you take the father out
of the whole if you have a great dad
that's just about to say that does great
co-parent and don't just see their child
like every weekend or every other
weekend has an active
you know four days a week come like
involved and can i pick you back quickly
rings because i i'm piggyback right my
point is um
if you start a relationship and you guys
have a great bond as far as a friendship
ultimately in the end of that little
demise of the relationship you can still
salvage something i have a great
co-parenting relationship with my
children's dad when i go out dating i'm
not looking for somebody to replace him
or be
a father figure to my children i'm
looking for someone that can fulfill my
needs because i'm at a mature age where
and understand myself sexually i
understand myself as far as my ambitions
in life and like so many other things go
into that right do you want him to know
your children your new man um yeah
ultimately at some point but it's not
something that i'm going to be like
pushing towards do you understand see
this is the thing it's like and this is
what i was saying what it looks like for
you now out on the dating market because
men that you're going to be coming into
is going to be coming into your
situation is now looking at you and i'm
not saying you're not a great mother i'm
not saying you're not a great person but
men do not look men are looking at the
long term and they're looking at the
actual package and they're saying how
many children she got
yeah
what what kind of charmer is that
can i have and i want to take all of
that one well and there and they're
going to hear 15 years with someone you
said is a great father right and was a
good husband or boyfriend i know you
didn't get married but but and they're
going to see that as a lack of loyalty
and selfishness
that's how men that's how men see it
because because a lot of men like the
reason women leave 70 to 80 of the time
um on top of that if you're a college
educated women leave 90 of the time so a
lot of men are looking at this dating
market and just seeing a lot of selfish
women that put them ourselves above the
family go ahead you had a question
what how does that dynamic change when
it's the man that also has children
because a lot we're talking about the
woman i know kevin samuels i did watch a
lot of his stuff like has we're looking
at so men don't find it acceptable if
you're a mother i personally don't have
children yet but
don't find it acceptable if you're a
mother but they may have children of
their own so how does that um actually
directly how does that balance out sarah
sorry you have a child do you want to do
you want to date someone with a kid
um that's my decision i'd prefer not to
but if it happened
i'd prefer not to i'm just gonna say i'd
prefer not to um because i've already
done it i've done it before i've done it
for like 10 years so i'm like oh i've
done it's not the same yeah and it's not
the same no it's not in you yeah it's
not the same as a father it's not the
same as because father's
father's generally someone said how
sorry go on no
you can answer it but do you want me to
answer please
um because
when a father has their child they have
their child um
not like the mother has their child the
the mother has the child the father and
due to unless you're an actual single
parent father
right you don't have the child so a man
also when he's looking for a woman is
not looking for a woman to become
stepfather to his child
he's not looking for that well
a woman generally is looking for a man
to become stepfather to her kids well
and and there's about where you can't
undo how we are biologically
and in in history if a man had children
that was a sign of pre-selection from
other women so that that's a sign oh he
can take care of those kids he can take
care of those women he can take care of
me too so we're we're attracted that
we're men um they they don't like girls
with a high body count because that
signals that the kid possibly could not
be theirs and so if there's actual
that's body count if there's evidence if
there's an actual child that's that's a
sign that she slept with other dudes
and that also goes back to cheating when
men men and women cheat differently
because
when men cheat
there's no
question about paternity or maternity
about the child when women cheat there's
always a question of paternity so women
think they can cheat the same as men
which is why you've never seen the mori
show and there's a mother on there like
am i the mother of the baby no i've
never seen that
right but you've always seen am i the
father of the baby because no one's
questioning that so when women cheat
it's totally different to when menchie i
know i definitely agree with that a
hundred percent when it comes down to
paternity but
are we are you saying sorry um that
as as a man with a child you you expect
a woman to date you with your child but
you wouldn't no it's not a choice
it's her choice but it's
it's more what is it it's supply and
demand right so so women care less about
men's kids wow yeah we're like i see in
pacific chicago yeah i'm 25 right so
there's girls my age that are willing to
date guys with kids as long as you could
take care of them
don't get me wrong like they're not well
some girls still date broke guys with
kids but typically
but but in general but men it's just not
the same because it's like
when a guy
thinks about you like with another dude
it makes them sick like they just don't
they don't want to know they don't yeah
i didn't know this yeah
yeah yeah like don't mess with me
yeah and so and you got actual evidence
and that's just a girl being with
another guy when you have actual
children yeah like what in the animal
kingdom they kill the children they take
the wife kill the children
and also a guy when he's coming into
your life he knows whether consciously
or subconsciously he's gonna have to
take care of the household and those
household that household includes your
children yeah right a woman who's coming
into my life knows that i've already got
my household on on on lock so you ain't
gotta take care of my child i want
somebody that's going to be there for
your child like a i mean to some degree
but i don't require it it's like i've
already got everything that no but i've
got everything when it comes to my child
i've got everything that i need for my i
don't need you to come here and say oh
i'm going to be a no you're going to be
stepmom now you don't require that it's
fine don't worry about it
no but men because men when they take
over households there are children in
that there are children within the
household as a man he knows it's his
responsibility to take care of the
household
and there are children in that household
which means those are going to be his
responsibility
you should want somebody that is going
to come in and want to care and give
love to your child
sorry would you allow your stepdad um or
your new boyfriend to discipline your
child yeah okay
most mothers you know most mothers
wouldn't though right but that's because
this whole crazy thing of i'm gonna keep
this separate but i'm gonna try and date
and be with somebody but i have a child
question follow follow-up question so if
you if your child was acting up okay and
you did not feel like it required him
like hitting the kid but he did
would you would you there's other ways
of discipline no no no no no no no no
but see that's that's saying that's okay
so you're right so you're you're really
slapped my child yeah would you give him
that that authority it depends what has
been
okay so so it's a no so the answer but
this is wait wait let me let me finish
so so but what you're actually saying is
he doesn't get the authority because you
want to decide but like relinquishing
control is saying you get to decide and
you get to pick the guy
so you you'd get to determine if he
would be a good stepdad but it's if he
fills that role does he get all the
authority even if you don't agree i hope
that i pick the right one because if my
child knocks over a drink and it spills
and you slap my child there's something
wrong right but you're going to the
extreme we're not talking about this so
then what can women do
it makes the answer
but i just want to know what the thing
because you could say oh they touch
something and i want to slap them but
okay so what's the level of it because
it
so
right right but we're not we're not
going all the way to the extreme maybe
maybe he's being he's talking back he's
saying you're not my dad like being
extremely disrespectful and he he thinks
he should be able to slap the kid okay
well obviously there's an extreme
situation going on so i'm going to leave
you to handle that and
if i disagree we can talk about it later
amongst us
if you're in my house of course for you
to be
around my child and disa we've been
together for a while that was just like
that's not just something where we've
met i've met somebody they've come in
because they're just sucking up my child
i was with a woman i was with the woman
who had a child right this is anecdotal
evidence right i was with a woman who
had a child right i was with her for 10
years and i knew
at every step whether it be a conscious
conversation or a subconscious one that
i was only supposed to go so far
with the discipline of that child yeah
right and mothers know that if they
bring a man into their house their home
the men
feel that they know they can only go so
far with the discipline of that child
however that man gets 100
percent of the responsibility as a dad
right but he doesn't get 100 percent of
the responsibility when it comes to the
discipline and the guidance of that
child and i'm saying it's a and that's
why a lot of men are saying it's a bad
deal for men to be with women who
already have children i think because
i've seen it i've got a stepdad and i've
seen it in my house where he's
disciplined like my brother who was
acting up and needed a little box around
his head and wasn't told oh my mom
didn't come through like what are you
doing
like it was just normal because at the
end of the day as much as you're my
stepdad you are the man in this house
you are the father figure in this house
yes we have a dad and yes we see that
but you are here so for me it's normal
it's not i'm not looking at it like no
you can't you can only do this or you
can only do that or yeah but you are a
little you are a little bit because
before when you're saying well it
depends what he's doing because but that
at the time my brother deserved the box
so that's why i asked it to you because
you just said it like oh if he's
actually
depending on what happens
i'm hoping that that situation was
deserved well yeah but what i'm saying
is in this situation you would disagree
but you like would you be able to if
he's he's disciplining your kid in a way
that you you don't agree with right and
you don't think it was necessary would
you be able to would you be able to
that's that's the point he doesn't get
the authority
it's necessary to slap a child from
knocking over a cup right but i'm saying
like
but the point the point is being
submissive i'm talking about the child
the point the point the point is that
being submissive is relinquishing
control
and giving the man control and authority
and being able to shut up even when you
don't agree
and so yeah okay okay a cup i don't
agree with that i can't what should i do
allow my child to get beaten well right
but i'm not saying beaten up like you're
going to the extreme example
that's why i can't keep my mouth shut if
it doesn't feel right as a mother
it's not going to happen but if it's i'm
i'm going to allow you to be that person
in my house of course well the point is
i mean you have to pick wisely yeah
right the point is you do have to pick
wisely but when you do pick there are
going to be situations
where you are not going to agree and
that man like wants to have the
authority and not have you nagging on
him being like oh i don't like that was
wrong you can't do that you can't do
that like it's just shut up and let him
discipline the kids and if you can't do
that like that's why guys don't date
single moms
can i ask a question we kind of straight
though yeah
yeah i was going to read super chat real
quick real quick and then we'll get back
into it okay guys as you know thank you
for the super chats because we are
trying to get ish a camera
yes sir
so chris a hundred dollar super chat
let's go
to the lady in the middle ma'am i am a
man who makes 100k a month and trust me
women like you don't intimidate me using
the word
intimidate is how
women like you cope with the fact that
men don't want to deal with you and only
view you as side chicks swell city
does she read or look at these super
chats
um okay uh leia e when dating single
women
women with children does it make a
difference if the woman is a widow
um actually i'm gonna ask do you think
it makes a difference if the woman is a
widow
oh good question yes yes
because what why
competition
i feel like it's the same no it's not
because there's no competition
i just feel like um
it's like she did it the right way she
got married had the kid yeah
yeah kind of you know it's not as
indicative of
a pattern of behavior that resulted in
no longer being married
out of their control
yeah
sarah do you think it's different if the
girl's a widow um i think it is because
you no longer have to deal with
um the actual biological father i think
it actually is a bit different okay
elia e when dating um oh wait i did that
one dj wolf hey pearl your videos made
my 12 hour drive a breeze thank you
dragon stallion1001 sorry but no man
wants to spend their resources on
raising another man's kids
ryda it becomes mod it's because modern
women don't need men they can leave
relationships over not feeling happy
king gil
gamish if women only want men and not
need them men think that tomorrow you
could want someone else men think long
term will you not want us in 20 years we
cannot guarantee that you won't want us
tomorrow can i answer that go ahead if i
want you i chose you so if i choose you
i'm not just going to decide for no
reason i'm not going to want you no more
i think you you have to be secure in the
situation that you're in if somebody
didn't you a little bit
as far as elaborate like when you were
talking earlier he's a good dad you said
he is he's a good provider doesn't mean
he's a good partner
it just it just does but i'm just i'm
not getting like a real good dream when
i was young i grew up people evolved
together from the 18th but see this is
you're proving men's point though
this is this is this is like their point
is there's no
women change their mind like the wind
man like it's just it's just
you can have the most
perfect
perfect situation
and still say
no
and then once you get like i said once
you get out into the dating market and
it goes tits up then you're up you're
upset you're angry you're bitter these
men these men are trash these are this
it's like you had a good situation love
like you you left to somebody else's
perspective to the outside world it may
look like the ideal situation but only
you know what true happiness is for you
right now
when you are in a long-term situation
like i said you evolve and you grow
right so if you're not both evolving and
growing at the same pace
sometimes you feel like that person is
holding you back a little bit in life
but but marriage is the choice of saying
i'm gonna put this and i know you guys
weren't married but what typically like
a 15-year relationship i think you may
as well have been
but it's putting
the family above my personal happiness
and duty above happiness and so that's
why like like that would be a red flag
to guys and i can i can respect that
like and that just wouldn't be the right
guy for me and my point in saying that
is at the end of the day
i did sacrifice everything my own
happiness for my family but when you get
to a point where you are literally
depressed and you're upset and you're
crying every day and you don't know why
you're crying and all of these things
are happening and you don't feel
supported as an individual you do have
to sometimes make a sacrifice i am
happier
like i have a good he is a good dad so
i'm lucky in that way that my children
haven't necessarily lost out completely
you've been broken up for long yeah um a
year
give it to you so i have a question i
have a question um
um how old did you say you are
um i'm 30 so if you were 42 and you
didn't find anyone else would you still
feel the same way
as far as like like if you were still
single at 42 would i still feel the same
way about leaving yeah about leaving um
or let's let's actually you know at
least 52 62.
would i regret oh my god why would i be
single with that
because because
no because you're good at you're running
out of time one at a time because it's
going to be hard with as a single mom
with three kids and this is where the
contradiction comes in
i'm not being funny if i can accept when
i initially first initially was like
yeah i did actually go through a stage
where i was like i want to be celibate i
don't want to give myself abstinent let
me say that because sometimes
james is like nars you know
okay absolutely i decided i'm gonna you
know refrain from being sexually active
with somebody no matter if i'm dating
them
and um
i decided to do that so that i can
really go into a situation with fully
like my whole you know being like
mentally emotionally spiritually
everything involved
dating now compared to when i was with
my ex i was a different person i'm
emotionally evolved now i understand
what real love is i'm not now accepting
toxic behavior as a form of love because
i've now discovered who i am so then the
person that will get me at 40 years old
at 50 years old is getting a different
version than he had
when i was 18 and 20 years old but but
it's a it's a less valuable version to
match um no that's not the right man for
me because no it's not it's not it's not
the right man for you it's how man like
men can't help what they're attracted to
no it is all men they can't if you
survey men
if you survey men between the ages of 20
and 80 they're all the most attracted to
22 year olds i peaked three years ago
and
and and and you guys did too what are
you yeah
at 20 22 23 and and and this is men
between the age of 20 and 80. so what
men value is purity
youth and fertility
and so like what would you be able to
offer to a guy
if you can't you're not a man that's
looking at 20 year olds so
you might be like
about those 20 years no at 50 if you're
50 and you're saying oh okay and i'm 50
and you're gonna turn around and tell me
oh i'm i want somebody that's 20 years
old or okay he are you would you how old
are you i'm think right would you be
open to dating a 50 year old no right
now okay but that's that's the problem
so if you don't know if you don't if you
don't do if you don't do an age because
the 50 year olds may not want a 22 year
old but they do want a 32 year old right
but if you don't give the 50 year olds a
chance the guys your age you're looking
at the girls my age that's right and
that's and that's
right
i'm 45.
right
do you ladies seriously think that 32
year old men are looking at
32 year old women nope no i don't we've
used with children
yeah
because i know that's some problem
i don't think oh i'm not saying i can
talk on every man do know a few men that
are like okay i'm 41 that are dating
people i'm 41. yeah and i know
that
worst case scenario
best case scenario i can get someone
who's 25. right at 41. worst case and
get someone my own age right
women when they hit 41
the same options are not open
like and if a woman is 41 and she's
getting 25 year old we already know what
that's for mm-hmm do you know what i
mean it's not for any kind of long-term
you know partnership like so do you
think the 25 year old this with the 41
year old is for a long-term partner yeah
i would i would i would date i would
date a four-year-old
but what happens when she gets more
established in life
when these women here were 16 yeah when
these women were 16 the 16 year old boy
is their age you never had no pocket
money we're not attractive to them
remember that the 19 year olds who went
their stuff together i did the older
boys
were looking way more attractive than
them boys in your class would know what
oh guys guys one at a time one at a time
please thank you much
go ahead
in general i know that is a thing
because now if you look at it obviously
doing podcast lives and stuff people
talk to us and be like oh yeah i
remember when i was in uniform and my
guy was coming to pick us up so these
big men were coming to school to pick up
the little girls to say okay look
so i know i'm not naive but it's just
not my heart
but when
but you see how that that yeah i can see
how at that point the age gap i
definitely see i get it i know it's
there 50 of your options are gone by 30.
even if you on date according to dating
app data so and that's without that's
without children
so if you add a kid on that it's like
smaller and smaller and smaller pool and
that's from that's right
yes and so and that's that's why kevin
samuels always said you don't get better
than your baby daddy
oh that's such an interesting point and
can i just ask then is it more likely
did you finish stupid that's okay well
we'll finish it a little bit good
um
is it more okay quick question is it
more likely that a woman that has
children and is past the age of 30 is
like likely to get cheated on
yeah because you have less leverage
like so so okay say i'm 20 i'm 25 right
if i'm dating a guy for two years let's
say i get married to him right no no
kids yet
i i can leave and go get go get someone
else
but every every year you wait the older
you get the less options you have so i
gave my best years to my children's
father yes this is what i'm hearing but
i don't understand i feel like i'm in my
best years now i don't understand the
shock though i think i think it's like i
feel like a lot of things but reality is
different i feel like i'm 120 pounds
but reality is different it just kind of
drives home that that woman like someone
would live in such a different reality
yeah that the idea of these things are
like
shocking but i think for a man it's like
really common sense yeah i have this a
lot where
you know in in the social scenes i'm in
there'll be one gorgeous girl and she'll
she'll be great at the start she'll
maybe get with two or three of the top
guys
and then you know she'll realize i'm a
cool dude and she now thinks i'm gonna
take home four days and have a serious
relationship with her and she's actually
shocked that i weren't like
honest to god her face is like eyes wide
open like i can't believe this
it's just very yeah it's very
interesting say something is that
because and to drawn kevin samuels again
you look women don't necessarily look at
their tears so what i've noticed with
some of my female friends is that when
they're stating all these things like
the six foot one the this the salary
that i'm like well hunger
what are you doing like what are you
bringing to you know the classic to the
table i am the table you're not though
you're not bringing something to him to
suggest that you're of that level
to be eligible to date that man but you
still think that you're worthy of dating
that man but you're gonna drain all
their resources and then do it in the
name of oh but i i want that that's that
to me that's that's where
well that's why kevin would say height
weight dress size height weight dress
size that's your starting point and then
what it would like each kid subtracts
two points
that's a science yeah so it's not like
you're dating within your sorry dating
within your tears so as in you know
you're within your lane if you're in a
in a similar lane i'm obviously as you
mentioned men always would like not
always but typically men would like to
have some um authority over their woman
that's fine or be somewhat a higher rate
but you you still need to look within
what is your category you can't be a
fiat 500 and looking at a hummer and
feeling like yeah feeling hard done by
because unfortunately that's not your
bag i'm like the problem is though
or a problem is that when you have a
group of guys who hit the club and
there's one guy in the group who doesn't
do as well with the ladies as the rest
of the group after the guys are finished
teasing him yeah if they're really he's
bros yeah yeah they'll pull him aside
and they might give him a couple
pointers and say you know what bro you
might want to switch this up you might
want to switch that up that's what bros
do yeah yeah
what the sister code is is you just
ain't make the right one
no no no no no no no no no that's true
yes it is one voice yeah one voice
it's not it is not raw um you know what
maybe
the reason why we all get attention from
guys and you don't might be a you
problem maybe you need to change
something about you no we don't
generally that's not what we do let's be
real we don't do that we we we we make
ourselves feel good and we say babe you
just say make the right one for you just
be real yeah i'll be you know i did a
whole show we talked about fat phobia
and people and they're saying that fat
girls deserve love nobody deserves love
no no but i'm saying just like short
broke guys don't deserve what nobody
deserves love you get what you deserve
and if you end up by your damn self that
says something about you
it's not you lot's fault because it's
not today's women's fault yeah i'm not
even blaming no one who's here today
it's not your fault but you gotta
understand yeah that
women have had a loud voice in terms of
dating in terms of your standards your
expectations who you want what you want
what you aspire to want men have heard
it all we've heard it all from childhood
we've heard it all and i'm not saying
it's you because you were a kid with us
but we have heard it all and here's the
thing
i think men
as a result of this are far more in tune
with the wants of women than women are
with the real ones of men because we had
the same voice you've had that's why we
know you better that's why we game you
the way we do because we know because
men know whether you're a winner or a
loser the the guy who gets all the girls
and the guy who gets no girls they both
understand your nature do you get it
yeah i agree they both get you you had
to right yeah whereas whereas you don't
get us because you get cheated or you go
let me see what that [ __ ] looks like
yeah i feel like women don't listen they
don't learn right they will just they
will have things happen and then repeat
the cycle it wasn't
it's always someone else's fault but
that's why i said
women that's why if you get cheated on
it's your own fault take accountability
there you picked them you picked them
take accountability and that's what we
did when i got cheated on i know why it
wasn't oh how did why did he do this to
me i know it was what i was doing in the
relationship
yeah yeah but there are a lot of women
that don't which i understand they just
kind of that's the lack of maturity
though
honestly it's not even mature there's a
lot of old women who are still
delusional out here like it's i think
that's the issue with the dating market
right now is that most women are
absolutely delusional in the sense that
everyone thinks they're a prize it
doesn't matter how many kids you got how
many guys you've been through everyone
thinks they're right
i mean i meet five foot two waitresses
who sit sit beside me in a dating table
and ask me to prove myself to them
i'm looking at them everyone knows and i
think what's tough about being a woman
is they have to learn the hard way in it
they'll have to learn slowly yeah a
little bit well that's why the largest
growing homeless population is women
because if and this is the thing a lot
of women are banking on government
handouts and you don't know if those
will ever go away in the uk or the u.s
one day they could be gone like that and
if that happens and you don't have 2.5
million to retire
you're on the streets so can i ask a
question based on that because that's an
interesting stat
when we're talking about men wanting to
obviously earn more than females and we
were discussing earlier about women
being more empowered to work and etc
where does that sit with men so looking
at the start of women are becoming
homeless because they don't they haven't
sorted out to make sure that they have
something they're relying on men that
they're not eligible for therefore they
think it's fine to just laze around and
rely on a man because for me personally
i wouldn't rely on a man fully
financially or a woman for that fact i i
wouldn't do that just because well for
two reasons one i like the feeling of
being able to gift and provide but it
doesn't mean that i wouldn't allow them
to also treat me or be the one that
spends more but women just think that
they don't need to work because why why
don't you need to work do you know what
it is
and i said there isn't there is an
energy
and a um
there's friggen energy there's a
psychology that comes along with a lot
of women who are successful okay and
like i said a lot of women who have
become successful within the corporate
world specifically have had to become
more masculine just to get ahead because
it's in a male-dominated world okay so
you've had to become more masculine and
you've made more money and you've become
this shark you've become this tiger
right yeah there's not i totally
understand why you've got you've had to
do that
if you go to a man with that energy
it's game over not the man you'd respect
yeah but that's it's just getting all
over that point the man you'd respect
that doesn't mean you don't become
submissive to your man
though women find it hard to do so
because they because those degrees that
money that boss chick mentality becomes
their persona
you know what i mean they they embody
that i'm a boss i'm of this it's like no
man wants to deal with that for real you
can also be you're vulnerable you're
you're still dedicated to your partner
you can still be and allow yourself to
rest because that's one thing for me i'm
as i said extremely successful well to a
degree and sometimes i just want to i
don't want to have to do that all the
time so it's nice to be looked after
when you're someone who's always bossing
it bossing it having to do everything to
be able to come home and have that meal
cooked be picked up be treated
take back
wait a minute
yeah to be looked after that's a treat
um
no but what i will say is that i enjoy
being submissive in a relationship i
feel like if i can't be
in my
whole feminine energy
and feel like i'm the female in the
relationship when i come home regardless
what i'm doing on my on a professional
basis if i can't be that then somewhat
you're missing a little bit of masculine
within you that doesn't just i'm saying
like i feel like i'm not women it allows
women who are masculine choose feminine
men
really they're there
um i said they can only get feminine man
because any masculine dudes me and my
boys like we can't even see the
masculine women like
they
women complain to me about men it's
always
rather masculine women complaining about
very logical issues which always shows
to me you're dating feminine dudes and
the reason that dating feminine dudes is
none of the top guys are having it and
when you say feminine by the way you
don't necessarily mean effeminate yeah
because those feminine men don't know
they don't always know their feminine
men you get
they don't know that their results are
glaringly obvious but they don't know
that's who they are and you know what
i'll say a lot of women have and a lot
of men have substituted masculinity for
aggression thank you so they think that
the most aggressive man or the most
don't mess you up
they think that's masculinity while that
is masculine energy the guy can't put
nothing together right he doesn't know
how to manage his finances he doesn't
know how to manage a house but the thing
is what he can do is display masculine
energy because like i said women are
attracted to men women can get turned on
by two men fighting right they don't get
turned on by two men fighting right and
that because they are displaying their
masculine energy that don't mean the guy
knows how to deal with the finances in
the home and you see when you talk about
and see me talk about a man who grows up
into the sort of man who maybe doesn't
have
a full arsenal of coping skills as well
right yeah here's the thing i find
really interesting right
when women end up as single moms
half my family that's this that's their
situation i don't judge that's not what
i'm here for but what i'll say half the
time when that situation happens
there's the whole i was young it was a
mistake
shouldn't judge me should it blame me
these things happen all right cool yeah
but then you see
if it goes wrong and the dad's not in
the picture
typically whatever
that son
who then grows up without that dad
you know the women his age when he grows
up they make no allowances for
the deficit in his development as a
result of the dad that these same women
will also say in the same argument
it's not that deep
because it's like i was only a mistake
it's not that deep
we
more women can do it by itself now these
days anyway like there's all these
arguments why it's like it's not that
big a deal but then those boys they grew
up as affected men you know yeah and
women don't make no allowances for men
like that they get left on the shelf
right but the thing is those men are the
men that women are like i said those
those hyper aggressive
can't do anything outside of just be
aggressive men right are the men that
women get attracted to and then when
those men act like children yeah right
because that's what they are they grow
children right oh these men
no yes no you chose that guy
you chose that grown child well it's
because the same the same traits that
make the guy the hero make him the
villain
and so so the reason like a lot of girls
they're girls that stay for years with a
man that abuse them and you're thinking
like why on earth why on earth would you
do that well a lot of times they don't
mention that she was also abusing him
too because most abusive relationships
are mutual a lot of times they they
forget that part but you wonder like why
is she saying well it's because she
knows that if he can beat me up he can
protect me
and it's it's a weird biological
function but we can't help what we're
attracted to
um can i also quick question
um who is more likely to cheat the
masculine male or the feminine male
masculine the feminine male the
masculine masculine probably
because he's because he's got more women
that are attracted to him
what about the feminine male being
slightly more vulnerable or weaker so
therefore they're more beautiful yeah
i'm just wondering you know what my take
is i feel like the feminine guy
just as likely would but he can't that
bit that's what i was going to say
quickly though this is interesting
43.7 of cheating women
and 22.2
of chi in men have cheated with this
cheated on their spouse with somebody
that they both know
that they both know
is she looking real sad
so women cheat more
with men or with people that both of
both her and her spouse know can i ask a
question is that
sorry i'm looking at you is that because
they want it to hurt more is is anyone
thinking that that's why because it
hurts more like i'm looking at you just
literally into here
it's a case of
the people around you are the people
that you spend the most time with and
it's where the relationships especially
for women will develop
and that's how you create an emotional
attachment from time spent with the
person and therefore
that is the statistics would be higher
with people that you know that you'd be
cheating with there was a there was a
video out the other day that went viral
with a girl coming home to her man and
her she was in um her man was in bed
with her mother did you see that
yeah yeah she still see that one told
her
what did she say to her daughter she's
like you about taking care of me yes you
are taking care of him no
yeah yeah yeah
and the mama's living in her house mom
was living in the house
i'm saying
like a lot of people are cheating with
people that people both know that's mine
earlier earlier on in this conversation
yeah i believe generally we agreed
unanimously that when it comes time to
sex
that
for women
generally
more emotion is attached to that sort of
decision yeah so
i don't know if i'm reaching now but i'm
just thinking like
like
if men are less emotionally led with who
they sleep with then maybe there's less
consideration for those
for those men who the women are cheating
with because those men are they careless
they care less about who they sleep with
whereas women care about who more they
sleep with so it doesn't surprise me
that a higher amount of
men
okay it doesn't surprise me that women
would have slept with a higher amount of
men that are like crazy because they're
familiar so how would you do that that's
crazy but then that's maybe because
the men in question
are not as concerned as the women are
hence why the men are sleeping with a
far less percentage of women that they
both know
jesus jesus
do you think cyber sex cyber whatever
they call it is cheating yes yeah if you
if you don't actually meet the person
yeah but you have yeah
if you have no it might not just be cool
it might be someone that you met on a
app
and you guys decide to have
i think it's time to meet yeah either
way that's your time to leave bro
is that cheating that's still never met
them i think
as a girl i could i think i could more
get past something like that more than
physical cheating but it's still
cheating you know you're engaging i
might just give it a blind but maybe we
can do it again and we can
are we listening to what you're doing
like you're like on the screen
no i don't know you need help you're on
the screen on a screen with somebody i
think i could understand more that you
went and physically touched somebody
that's only fan stuff
like only no that's different that's
like corn so that's different can we
actually
engaging so are you talking about
just witnessing as in corn or you're
talking about engaging with disgusting
engagement for me is
no engagement
so once you've engaged in
um discussions of a sexual nature or
you've gone over
the boundary of where the the
conversation is pc or flirting so if
we're saying flirting is cheating how
could we possibly then say
that level of that's an intimate act
that you're doing whether or not it's on
a screen or not is totally irrelevant
you've gone into sexual act with the
person just because it's cyber doesn't
mean i mean we're getting into black
mirror territory here but yeah you know
um
you know i to me that's not
that's not appropriate i have a question
has anybody caught someone cheating in a
crazy way
[Music]
i've caught one of my
friend's partners cheating oh wow it
wasn't one of my how
um it wasn't crazy but i see it like in
a club
it's a classic in a club scenario
they saw me they thought they could duck
out it's too late bro like
look you look me in my eye like i see
you hey
how are you how's your mom like listen
we're here now
that scenario is crazy because depending
on how well you know i actually knew
both of them quite well you then in this
paradox of what do you do with this
information that you've got do you go
call your mate and explain
[Laughter]
it's a very difficult um in that
scenario it was very difficult for me
to know how to navigate the situation
because i also knew the partner quite
well and then you're stuck with this
sort of where does your loyalty lie do
you just stay out of it what i did was
then address the partner i'm like listen
here's what we're gonna do
we all know what's going on here so you
you're gonna have to let them know
either you're about to tell me you're
not in an open relationship and i'll
step out your business or i'm not
comfortable with just pretending that i
didn't see that so i'm going to give you
the opportunity to go tell them
otherwise i might snitch on you i don't
want to have to do that because i don't
want to be in your business but you've
done it clearly it wasn't agreed because
you tried to run so you know you're then
in that thing of are you gonna speak or
am i gonna have to do it for you which
is gonna make it a lot worse
if i have to tell them do you think for
the guys for the guys here do you think
it's different like if we saw one of our
guys cheating
and women saw one of their
one of their girls cheating
do you think it's different like or if
or for instance if i saw d
if i saw one if you if i saw your girl
cheating
i would say it's more likely for a guy
to tell his guy bro your girl was did it
today than it is for a woman to say you
know what your man was 100 could i just
add because
something that i find interesting is
that
in those scenarios say for example you
know one of your boys this libby one of
your boys is cheating
you may not be too well you might not
say to him oh mate i really don't think
you should do that but if you saw his
girl you found out his girl was cheating
i feel like we condone certain behavior
and then
it's kind of like oh it's all right if
you're on my own when it happens to us
yeah but i think some i think some girls
just don't want to know like they kind
of know and they would just rather but
men i i don't think it's the same they
would they would they want to know so
they can bounce and i think a girl
doesn't want to know because she wants
to stay regardless oh my god
i had a situation where um it wasn't
really trust me well i've had two
one where it was somebody else and i
didn't tell the girl because i knew she
would stay she what what's the point of
me causing the friction in something
that doesn't need to be you know what
your man does and then with with me one
of the um
times i was
safe
cheated
on
you call it cheating it's a whirlwind um
but yeah he had
basically three women
at the same time
and the one of the women who was adamant
that he was has
made like a little fact file thing and
sent it there's a movie about that
wait she made it wait she made a fact
file yeah so she basically put lot yeah
oh every receipt every picture
everything the other woman
put it in a folder and she sent it to me
oh and the other girls that were inv you
guys were all four of you were dating
the same guy yeah oh and she's such a
female thing to me
it's a whirlwind my man just replaced
all four with a minute that's what i
would have done
whoops
[Laughter]
why are men less forgiving about a woman
cheating on them than a woman
because men and women cheating is
different why can't you really ask them
kind of questioning yeah i'm sorry you
know what
and i've never cheated by the way let's
put that on the record but i'm just
saying like i just see a lot of men that
are way more heartbroken and way more
like
able to throw away a whole relationship
for a woman instead of looking and
thinking maybe i was less emotionally
available for her maybe i wasn't
mentally stimulating her what was i
doing where's the accountability
men when a woman cheats but when a man
cheats women must take accountability
for some part in in that situation
okay men and women are different
so so men can when a man cheats it
doesn't mean that he doesn't love you
he he just has like again guys see sex
as a handshake that's how they see it
women we release a chemical during sex
when we orgasm that mate that attaches
us to that guy that's why girls always
go back to the best sex of their life no
matter like it doesn't matter what the
hell he did she's coming back if that
was the best sex of her life right
but you know what i'm talking about
right right so this is what i'm saying
men and women cheating is different
because to man it's nothing to women
it's we we release a hormone they don't
so if a woman cheats she doesn't love
you
if a man cheats he still can
i'm not saying to accept cheating but
i'm just saying it's different yeah i
just wondered i've always wondered that
question so yeah it's
it's disgusting also you know if you're
done with it
also i was gonna say you mentioned i was
going to quickly say right you know
if you have a platonic friend
and like mixed mixed like guy and girl
platonic friends you know
[Music]
you see when
sorry you see when
if you've got a male friend
and your male friend catches your
boyfriend
cheating on you
depending on how bad your choice of man
is because most women not most i'm sorry
some
some women the judgment is a bit
questionable and then when it goes left
it's like oh my god how could he do this
to me yeah yeah
depending on the type of character
you've chosen to be with do you know
what position you've put your brethren
in when your virgin has to now think
this could escalate people get shot over
these type of teams
trying to tell you right you know your
boyfriend the gangster you chose to get
with i gotta tell you your gangster
boyfriend he's cheating on you
when you invest that can't lie i'm not
telling you
very much
i'm not risking my life i've been here
bro i've been there bro i've been there
bro i've had bad choice of friends
you've got bad choice of boyfriends i've
been there yeah yeah yeah
and when she asked me when she asked me
why didn't you tell me i'd be like yeah
i can't lie
i gave up speaking i gave up telling
women that their men are cheating on
them i gave up because the last thing
was like a few months ago it actually
happened to her to a platonic friend of
mine
and
i found out from another girl
that this girl's boyfriend was seeing
the both of them so i was like okay cool
i know this girl i'll call her do you
know what
this is what's happened
i've got some information about your
guide
he's seeing this other girl
what's she done she mad at you oh no
she went like
who is this girl
i was like hang on hang on whoa whoa i
said your boyfriend okay is cheating on
you and you want to know about the girl
yeah that's not right
she created she said okay
let me speak to her she spoke to her
and then the other girl got in contact i
knew both of them other girls gone to
contact with me oh she's a little bit
moving
she created a whatsapp group
no no i don't know why you don't do what
you're doing i ain't got time
i think with women i'm the same like
i'm not talking i don't know that i'm
because i know how women are yeah
they're ready to just be like who is she
first of all why are you mad at the
woman yeah talk to your man
why should another woman have any
loyalty so are probably going to stay
there and just do so what is the point
like well that that happened to me once
in college i told a girl that her
boyfriend was like cheating on her and
then oh my god she stays with him and
then the whole friend group's mad at me
so all of some of the awkward we're on
we're on campus
and like like she she wasn't mad at me
but all of his friends were like oh
she's a snitch she doesn't stay out of
people's business i'm like you're just
mad you got cheating
but that's the thing about it as i said
a lot of the time women and both men and
women know
that their partner is actually a cheater
yeah yeah they know they know
if we think we're going to tell them
information that they already know
but then does that mean that you a
question then about that does that mean
that you're gonna
tell your friend to look up how they
conduct their
relationship because you don't think
that their business do you know what i
mean like you know when people yeah no i
understand you know some people like
well
would you want your friend to have their
happiness are you supportive of how they
live is it something that's in line with
your values
fair enough i've got an answer so what
you do is
at the start of the relationship or like
when it's festering you tell them look i
think this is a bad idea yes i don't
there's red flags
like you probably shouldn't go there
yeah yeah now when they made their bed
let them lie in it i agree with what
you're saying because i think a lot of
the time we let off people let their
friends go and be with this person that
person you may have your views on it and
if you love your friend tell them
if you care about them in the same way
that something you were talking about
earlier slightly unrelated if you think
your friends are not getting the man or
woman of their dreams maybe they should
actually look at why that is i've done
that before yeah i'm like okay what
honey if you actually look at how you've
conducted yourself previously it isn't
surprising to me that get on the
treadmill that that person doesn't want
to be with you so you know if you're a
true friend you should be able to have
that communication with your friends as
adults to just
have a conversation if it doesn't if
they don't they don't have to take it on
that's the next thing but at least you
you you can have your peace and just let
them live quick quick question to you so
then midway through like the
relationship so you've already had that
gone through that phase do you feel like
you should still be trying to tell your
friend that's now had a situation happen
to them it depends situations for
example when my friend will continuously
complain about the same things with
their partner
drop me out
we've had this discussion i've given you
my advice and honest opinion you don't
have to take it but if you're going to
keep going in the same vicious cycle
i honestly don't really want to hear
about the same thing that your man or
your partner's done and you don't want
to take on anyone's suggestions in order
to make you happy but you're going to
keep emotionally dumping
things on me for absolutely no reason
you're draining me at this point and i
don't want to hear about it anymore so
i'll just remove myself from hearing
about your man i've done that people and
some women are actually addicted to that
toxic yeah the relationship they love
the drama they love the old world me
poor me pity me some women really do
love it and this is the same thing it
would also and i hate to say domestic
violence sometimes because even as you
pointed out in domestic situations
um it takes two right sometimes the
women they know the triggers they know
what they're doing to get a man to that
point and then they like the fact that
the man has to grovel and beg back and
do all of this and whatever there's so
many different aspects so the same way
with cheating oh you know the type of
man you chose
you know that potentially he could he
he's going to do that and he's going to
continue to do that but because you like
the fact that your friends will rally
around you or your friends will be the
ones that will call you and be like oh
my god i just saw him in marx and
spencer's and he was with sarah and you
know whatever whatever and it's that
attention seeking so and you can tell
and i've got friends certain friends
like that and you can tell when they are
just so like misery loves company yes
and i'm not a miserable person there's
only so much of my time i can give you
and so much of my energy that i can put
into your toxic situation i'm gonna give
my two two pence in and after that babes
you're on your own
and i've i agree with that for me
personally i've had friends where their
relationship was really toxic and i took
a break from being around them even
though i was friends with both of them i
was like i don't want to see this
anymore so i'll take a break until you
guys you don't have to stay with friends
you know if you don't agree with how
they live i think people condone certain
behavior and then they send out mixed
signals because one minute is oh your
man did this and that and then the next
minute when your homegirl cheats you're
like yeah he was a [ __ ] anyway why
are you saying turret was fine but you
were cussing out a man we need to stop
being so hypocritical and actually
either living your values and your truth
and and
expel that or
you're just living a lie basically so
for me it comes down to your more your
your morals and if you're actually gonna
portray that okay i'm gonna finish the
super chats real quick
okay um december zero eight one um women
want to be wanted men want to be needed
dragon stallion one zero zero one ladies
choose one a man who fulfills all of
your sexual needs but is a bum
or a man who fulfills all of your
financial needs and and is a good
husband but sucks in bed
well can you repeat that okay okay what
would you pick so a man who fulfills he
best sex your life but he's a bum
or a great husband
fulfills the financial needs but bad and
bad
oh my gosh what the age that i am right
now
when i was younger i would have chosen
the second option now that i'm in my
sexual maturity i need great sex vibes
and everything else i'm not gonna live
my name
hold on a second
i've done the whole housewife i've done
all of that i've lived that life listen
babes listen
babes listen we all we all need it and
it's amazing and you know what it does
it gives you confidence you step out in
this world
you'll say you can't make this [ __ ] up
have you ever seen a chicken become an
ex
[Laughter]
he can still have a little bit of
everything else right but guess what
that man that has great sex and might be
a little bit of a bum i could motivate
him to be a better
no but this is this is the problem with
women you think you can change a man no
they are
if he's going to be your age he's been
this way for 40 30 40 years right he's
not changing he's a wants a bum always a
bum bums don't just magically
like bum bums just don't magically get
jobs
they love being bummed
because of you it wasn't joined
it wasn't
and he does pat or not it's probably not
because of you
probably because he just wants to but
guess what i'm still inspired
okay okay what if your ex-husband or
your ex-boyfriend said that he was
responsible for your success because he
inspired you to an extent he was because
me watching
him aspire to be what he wanted to be
made me sit down and realize what do i
want to do well you should get back with
him then you know what i mean
what the hell are you doing
15.
years yeah
same
trick my
i'm advocating for your ex right now i
don't know you bro right i don't know i
don't know you right
take her back she didn't mean that she
didn't meet him
like i don't know bro like two you need
to work something out i'm just saying
like this this sounds fixable this
sounds fixable oh go ahead go ahead what
do you think
i'm not imitate the one that's providing
because what's the percentage of um
cheaters
uh 70. apparently yeah
yeah if a dude has good sex you know how
many girls are hitting him up for that
sex yeah and he's going to each person's
house getting a whole meal he has a
practice to get good
you're having the little small talk and
coming back to you from there
let me get my
of cheating females and 25.25.9
of chi in males did so because they were
bored with their sex life there we go
someone might just be there
and me are gonna get really friendly
but i'm saying um i have the good man at
home that's not bum but then i want to
be in my phone
he becomes a sad man weird exactly
because that's my husband so who's
fulfilling you sexually my pets man
the question was the man is dry in bed
he's rubbish i'm clearly bored sexually
right so are you just trying to hear me
i'm not justified but
you're you're your orgasm doesn't matter
as a girl oh yeah true let me just it
doesn't it don't no i'm serious like
you can't have everything like y'all
what you what you want you want a guy
with a good job you want you want you
want a guy with a good job yeah that's
that's taller than you i know i don't
know that
but you're hider taller i don't want
this oh he can always she's a general in
general okay in general to a good job
right you want him to be good looking do
you want to be attracted attracted to
him okay and and you want him to be
taller than you right now i want him to
be my you're verbally my hype but i've
dated small amount okay okay within it
okay
you want him to be attractive
you want him to have a good job yeah you
want him to be a stepdad
oh yeah yeah you have children and you
want him okay one at a time oh okay
sorry i didn't know and you want him to
rock your world in bed
i could rock you or if and if not and if
not no no no no no no no you can't
so let me
and you also want him to be good in bed
and if he's not you're going to cheat
with the post guy
the disrespect
and vile you might as well ask him or a
partridge in a pear tree
whatever it is
but luckily this is just a question and
that would never be because that's
settling
but you you realize this sounds like
this this sounds like
delusional people maybe people used to
come one second lady i remember there
used to be this this whole phenomenon of
wifey material yeah i don't know if it
went outside the uk but it was laughing
we all grew up we all know it yeah all
the girls claim to be wife material and
all the man then we're looking for a
girl who is wi-fi material we all know
that right
right the point i need to make very
clear on this platform today here is
that women i hope you understand right
that
i'm not a
[ __ ]
does not equal i am wi-fi material
whereas when women say i'm not um they
go uh well i'm not a i'm not a slapper
of course i have to
doesn't mean just doesn't mean you're
loose
you could be you can be you you don't
have to be loose there's a lot of things
you don't have to be you still ate wow
because men don't hear wife
if men don't hear wife how is it wife
and material can i ask a question to
throw it down you cannot someone could
answer this one first of all if men
don't hear wife how is that wifey
material two women are gonna have to
listen i mean answer that right
um they're gonna look at during the
dating process or before you guys become
exclusive or whatever
you have to vet and this is what we're
saying on our live the other day um
you you there has to be certain things
that you see an attribute you see in a
person that makes them husband material
wife material and if you don't see them
then you don't get to that point where
you're exclusive you just have to be
smart about it if a man decides that
he's going to wife someone that's quote
unquote a slag or not wifey material
right and and that doesn't make sense to
me because how can you not how can you
be a slack and be wifey material you
can't right so so if you can't be wi-fi
if you that's right so you were saying
there's a difference between
being wife material and not being a slag
right so
so in that same breath can you right let
me ask it then can you be a slag and be
wifey material
how does that none of it make sense how
does that link to one no no so what he
said he's saying there are more
standards for men when picking a wife
than just doesn't sleep or i don't slag
is a british term
so it's not it's not just it's not just
doesn't sleep around equals what no
that's not because because i've i've had
a girl that came on the show right and
she she had really low body count but a
lot of guys would overpass her because
of her mindset and so a lot and so
and so a lot of a lot of women think
their wife material because they haven't
slept around a lot
but it's not just about that it's about
the mindset and and what he's saying is
that mindset i don't know you guys
personally but that mindset's toxic but
you know like like like because you're
you're older than me you're 30 33
like to me it's like it's crazy you're
you're prioritizing sex is the most
important thing right now sex is
important to me only because i don't
need a man to do anything in my life for
me right now right right
now
right right now but like you have to act
with some sense of urgency you're not
getting younger and so if you're want
more children it does you might not want
more children you want a husband but
yeah do you want more sex do you want a
husband
can i just ask do you want a partner do
you want to i want a lifelong person one
at a time i do want a lifelong partner
and um and this is where like i said the
vetting process goes
it i have to see certain attributes
within you and likewise you have to see
that within me during our dating process
to see if we're really compatible in
that way yes i do want a lifelong
partner but at the same time i want
someone i can have fun with have
adventures with do this in that wave and
whatever i don't want to feel like i'm
going backwards in the sense of
go back to your goal
you don't get better than your baby you
don't get better than your baby daddy
that's the dude you gave everything to
because why would why would a guy pay
more for a lower product it's a it's a
worse product you seem like a nice woman
i'm not i'm don't take this personally
i'm not saying but but like like you're
older you have kids
and
it's like it's you're asking for a
higher price for a worse product no i'm
willing to compromise so he might not
have the height that i want he might not
have gone back to can i say that
he might not have the paycheck that i
wanted
right okay but he had he's he's
charismatic he's funny he gives me the
giggles he makes me excited he gives me
certain things and vice versa i also
give that to him in turn i'm willing to
compromise he might have children he
might have one or two baby mothers i'm
now willing to compromise because i
understand that in the marketplace i'm
of lower value in that sense so yeah i
think it's achievable if i lower my
standard a little bit
this guy doesn't seem real that you're
describing
he doesn't
even lower your standards
[Music]
the thing is
when you said like there's this thing
about
like a guy and a girl almost like having
a feeling that process at the beginning
and kind of assessing each other's vibe
i'm not listen i'm not trying to betray
the fellas the male viewership forgive
me but i've got to be honest we're here
for honesty right
i feel like because
men are
my humble opinion men i think are more
innately in tune with what you want
even if i'm not what you want i know i'm
not really what you want but i know what
you want
as long as i know how to act like what
you want i'll get what i want because we
all know what you want because we've
heard what you want our whole life to
see no scriptures
we've heard
but you see that um that mindset yeah
that mindset comes from a mindset
of a man
who regularly has sex with women right
do you understand that yes my god men
that don't regularly have sex with women
and don't generally know women they
don't know that all they know is
themselves they don't know how to kind
of play the game and get what they want
out of a woman and blah blah blah
do you think that's connected to why
then they have less sex because they
don't know how to play the field and
they don't understand well really yeah
because a lot of men do not know how to
play the game to get sex a lot of men
want sex from women right but don't know
how to play the game a lot of you've got
to learn women you've got a lot
sometimes you've got women say they
don't want liars they want liars yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
because if men told women the truth yeah
they wouldn't like men okay they really
won't like it doesn't matter women want
liars
there's a lot of there's a lot of men
vladimir
some of the most unsuccessful men in
love i might be the ones who listen the
most to what the woman in their life
claims to want
certain times you can be what a woman
claims to want
and then turn out you're absolutely not
what she wants to do
so should women go for the men that they
friends own no women women are sick yeah
you've got great you've got great guys
in the friend zone yeah you your friend
zones where it went wrong
you should be checking that's why you
should be checking because those are the
men with the with the with the actual
interior credentials that probably would
have worked for you but maybe their
exterior wasn't
that's what
obviously
surely
surely the issue is a bit deeper though
don't you think like because this this
is an issue for most modern women now
this level of like narcissism and
delusion that everyone's a 10 out of 10
and needs the top guy and you know no
matter what i've done or how old i am i
i still deserve this 10 out of 10 guy
with a six-figure charity surely just
telling these women hey just date your
friends and make the decision that makes
sense is not going to be the solution
because these aren't irrational people
that they
aren't they're not rational people so
surely the problem is a bit deeper
and the problem is the average guys are
popping now and it makes them mad
makes them angry because you know the
above average guys
yeah there's a lot of women who
some not all
there's a portion of women who they can
look back in their past and reminisce
about when they had so-and-so
they might feel like in their younger
years you know what i might still be
able to catch and keep a man like
so-and-so whereas nowadays it's more
like a memorial thing like i remember
when i was when me and so-and-so dated i
remember that i don't get mad like that
now but
you know what's happened to the average
guy go through average guys leveled up
thank you yeah thank you
and and the woman yeah who was
the the one that everybody wanted when
they were younger she's kind of looking
kinda a little bit
that's one solution but i i think i
think one thing we need to fix is the
media because i think yeah there was a
point in my life while trying to figure
out women yeah and i thought you know i
think the best way to do this is to just
read some romance books oh bro don't do
that and the level of [ __ ] i read
i still have to like oh no wash my
brains
no but it is to read it because jordan
peterson already had a lecture on this
he said if you read women's romance
novels women have very um
um very uh they have archetypes that
they like werewolf and it's got so crazy
like it was werewolf uh what was it
surgeon
a pirate
and this mysterious other guy and then
women get they get turned on but they
these romance novels sell in the
millions so yeah read women's room
he breaks stuff down so like
i love the fact that women generally in
terms of preference to men i respect the
fact though that it's not bias i respect
the fact that it's fair game and what i
mean by that is
is that a guy who feels like he always
gets the short end of the stick
never goes his way
on one hand he might develop a hate a
resentment for women or women and my
enemy we've all heard many talk like
that
but then there are some men who go you
know what
if i took a bit better care of myself or
improved my social standing improved my
income like women are not so biased that
like just because i never used to have
them things when i become that they're
not gonna hold it against me that i
never used to have that i'm now gonna
get treated as a man who has those
things yeah understand what i'm saying
those men become players though because
those men those men reach a level you
weak you work on yourself but then you
look at these women you realize these
women are basic as hell bro i was
chasing i was chasing women who dropped
out of school just because she had a
nice ass asking me to take her to the
restaurants and i realized yo this woman
is basically so what i'll do is i'll
date four or five of them yeah and i'll
entertain them and when they each of
them has their issue i'll just go on
hinge get a few more matches and replace
it like that yeah then there's no longer
i was gonna say before when you said
these girls have these standards and
then you surprised who they end up with
yeah that's not that's not by mistake
can i ask a question about wifey
material religions
so for example those you like the 25
year old as you mentioned or that's the
standard
if that 25 year old is aesthetically
pleasing and you're looking based on
aesthetics etc are you looking at the
core morals and values that will make
her a wife because if she's more
interested in for example the birkin
than the home and the children because
we're not going to put seven bedrooms in
a rolex or a handbag so for me it's like
if your focus is you want to look good
and you want to go to fancy restaurants
et cetera to me that's not a wife
because she's not thinking about keeping
a home looking after your family et
cetera you're looking at i think i think
older women i think older women value
that stuff more than younger women just
my experience also men are very happy to
take a few things off of their list
um to get what they want we compromise
yeah we are we are very good at
compromising with the list that we want
and so and the thing is also and the
reason why is because men's list isn't
that big
what's on your list if you if you don't
mind me if you've got a woman who you
know is going to be a good mother woman
who's know it's going to cooperate a
woman who you know is going to get with
the quote-unquote program um
a woman who's friendly
a woman who takes care of herself
you know it's like intelligence is
massive
you can't have intelligence is that if
at any point that's the number one i
don't care how cute you are if if you
ever strike me as dumb
i won't tell you but we're never getting
far
because
i'm not having dumb kids in 2024
you can't you need to have a social
intelligence yeah
but not just emotional all kinds of
intelligence
being attuned to reality that's why i
think the dating market sucks right now
because these women are not here right
it's more dangerous for women to level
up in life whilst single way more
dangerous for them than the man
when women say like i'm working on life
and i'm leveling up all these different
components of my life but doing this
with no man involved for the
heterosexual women obviously if no man
involved i think that is dangerous bro
because
reason being right because
sorry because
the things that come with said level up
in a female i.e
higher earnings
um
deeper moral understanding of where it
went wrong the last decade
etc etc
like
that doesn't
those things don't necessarily create a
fair enough balance for simply the age
aspect for it to really be a fair trade
off in the eyes of most guys i don't
feel i feel like basically if you were
with a guy and you were going older with
him fair enough your physical stunning
um
that whole aspect may come down
but
you're leveling up with someone you're
already with so you're not you don't
have the conundrum basically right of
the fact that you've leveled up in life
and you still have this issue where you
still now need to become attractive to
the sort of man that you perceive to be
where you're at you know and and that's
and that's a conundrum i think that has
left a lot of women on their own unable
to pair with someone um
yeah what about if your woman levels
above you know levels but goes above you
while you're in the relationship so for
example with myself she lives
yeah that's that's what happened with me
that's why i was asking because
because yeah you go above them somewhat
and then you're then dissatisfied with
the balance
honestly honestly like okay so you're a
high earner is that what you said yeah
so would you be okay if you got married
to a guy i know you're dating a girl but
i don't i don't know the girl girl
dynamic so let's let's talk guy right
would you be comfortable with him
managing the money is your money has not
money
yeah if we're married okay so however
managing it as in i don't have any
control over it yeah
no but i wouldn't even if i was a lesser
earner it's that i would still not be
comfortable with that yeah and and see
this is that like why men don't want to
date high earners is because it's it's
they often have a hard time
relinquishing control which is part of
femininity yeah
because
because for me like like i do pretty
well with this channel right but i i
hope to date a guy that i can trust with
the finances i don't have to deal with
it
like that that's my mindset and i cannot
oh sorry ramsey no just off of what um
dee was saying about it it's dangerous
for women
to be levelling up and doing the whole
i'm working on me i've been saying
oh sorry i can say from experience
agreed but i would say more that it
makes you because as a woman it makes
you live in your masculine it turns you
masculine so when you're then going back
into dating you have to
re-learn how to be soft how to be
feminine how to accept somebody to take
control because you've had to
you know you've taken control you've
gone all right cool do you know what i'm
gonna do this i'm gonna do that be
independent whatever so i definitely
agree with that what happens is it makes
the ultimate toxic being right you have
when women get into their masculine then
then when they come back back to the
feminine they try and mix up the best
parts of both so when it's convenient
they want to be masculine when it's
convenient so they'll say stuff like i
need a man who has more than me but i
also need really good sex but i also
need him to get give me the drains once
in a while these kind of ridiculous
things where it's like basically you
want to flip roles when it's convenient
same thing with men when men get
feminine and they start doing this whole
emotional stuff then they start becoming
controlling and toxic in a really weird
way same thing yeah but i wouldn't agree
with that that in
the the picking and choosing i think
it's more not all because there's
probably women out there that are 100
doing this we know this but i definitely
say with it's just re-learning how to be
soft and feminine because i think when
you've been so hard in that you don't
pick and choose you you're you're
programmed to just be that person all
the time well it's not a choice it's a
being it's it's either it's either your
phone yeah it's it's either it's either
you're feminine or you're not it's
either it's either you have it in you or
you don't know yes you do because
because you're either raised to be a
wife or you weren't holding them
for your environment actually respect
your journey the fact that you can
actually have self-reflection 100
percent introspection to say you know
what i was like this and it wasn't
really working out for me and you know
what i need to change i respect 100 100
percent
and there's and and it's interesting in
conversations like this how
how
and per if i'm speaking for myself
personally i understand it yeah speaking
to my own lived experiences family
friends local environment whatever i
understand it right but i do find it
fascinating sometimes how in
conversations like this
women who struggle with being in tune
with their femininity for whatever
reason
seem it seems to be a notion that is far
more expected to be understood by the
fellas
then
women understanding men who may battle
with their masculinity because to some
women the notion of a man who battles
with being a man is crazy
but but it doesn't sound crazy to you
um how me as a man would hear i'm dating
this woman who's battling with being
feminine
i kind of i think i'm
i think because i've had moments in my
journey where i've reflected i've
understood when i meet men and i realize
are they coming to me in this energy
i get it and i'll be that person if you
want to talk or maybe let me shed light
on certain things that maybe someone
expects said to you but i i do
it's both crazy okay i'm gonna read
super chats because i i feel bad i'm
sorry chad
um you've had some good questions today
um a lot i had complaints last time i
always get complaints about my reading
the super chats that i don't ask the
questions that you guys put in so i was
trying to work on that but now the chat
is saying i don't read all of them look
it i can't you can't have everything
okay
so jose perez yo pearl i need you on
fresh and fit i've been on fresh and fit
you're going to be huge in this space
and i recently started watching your
videos you haven't missed the red pill
is strong in you um it's funny to hear
all of the accents um dan lady and
i bassara 44 damn lady and red i feel
for you guy on your guys on your
financial level won't check you
seriously and guys below you you'll
eventually hate because you wear the
pants um the lady in red 45 year old 45
gets real lonely grow up red belongs to
the streets 90 free free to pay what up
pearl i've i have i see the tan wore off
as a sunburn please ask the female panel
how they would
this is a good question i'm going to ask
it how would you keep a man outside of
sex
um
mentally and emotionally how um i would
be there for him like what he really
needs like you like i said you you have
to figure out the person you're with so
you work out their strengths their
weaknesses so you figure out okay how
can i be of service to you how can i
help you fulfill your full potential and
can i also answer yeah outside of sex
sex is not the beyond endle guys okay
all right let me just make that very
very clear it's not
it's just that i spent many years not
putting sex as a priority
and i'm wearing everything else you are
moon walking right now bro
it's michael jackson
eddie hayes
i don't multiple dates so i just want to
make that very very very sounds like
you're disrespecting your guys this is
the remix oh my god i can't win it just
seems like i can't win
for me outside of sex is mental um
stimulation you have to be intelligent
you have to be able to see they're
asking what you you give what i'll give
like emotional intelligence and mental
stimulation
okay what do you say um i would
outside of sex obviously i'm just gonna
be
the woman for my man whatever it is that
he needs whether it's like nurturing
caring for him just being there what
okay but you really you realize you
realize being there is like nothing like
anyone can be there that's the minimum
okay so by the way i'm a very good coach
i exist around my man and that's what i
give him every day and i give him i
reply to his thoughts
and i and i give him femininity which i
i've admittedly struggled with
have you noticed that when you ask women
what do they think
a man wants hmm
it's a bag of discombobulated nonsense
right
if you said that would have been a good
answer if you ask men but that's what do
they think women as a woman we can be
very structured oh they want to protect
it
hang on hang on
for some reason women just like dee was
saying earlier on men have been
listening to women for so long that we
understand what women actually want yeah
women have been listening to themselves
for so long yeah that they have no clue
what men want yeah
i can cut they got clue i don't care
about anyone and they don't even know
anyway
can i add i think also things like
support for the family so i think that's
very important for men if a man's a real
man he will also respect his mother
respect if he has a father his family so
also being a part of his extended family
i know a lot of women who may become
wives or partners and they're there just
for the man but what about when his mum
needs something or needs taken to an
appointment or you know nieces and
nephews showing that you've got more to
give than just it's not just me chilling
around my man watching what he's doing
this is contributing actively to towards
his tribe and his family unit to show
that you've placed yourself correctly in
that and you have something to offer
beyond just your body that benefits his
wider community that's what what else
what else so on top of that i would say
obviously
for me it is it is things like keeping
the home respecting him being able to
show that when you're with him that
you're um a trophy in the sense of not
just physically but a trophy in the
sense of you conduct yourself properly
you're a respectable individual you have
the correct values that they keep if
you're for me i'm quite spiritual so if
there's spiritual mental attributes for
that sometimes men are not always strong
so sometimes men go through difficult
times okay okay okay no seriously i want
to hear from the guys is there anything
is there anything anything then
statement no no i want to i want to hear
from the guys is there anything they
said that would be a value that was a
filibuster
anything any what do you guys want from
a girl i said earlier on okay remember i
said someone who's a good mother right
someone who's uh
someone who's intelligent like my man
said over here right someone who you
know who's going to get with your
program mm-hmm uh it's
our list is not very all of that
what the like what the hell was that
what are you doing all right well what i
want to be submissive
what are we doing from there
so what i want is um someone who's
at least as intelligent as i am minimum
right
um someone who's physically fit and
takes care of their health i've dated
people who are 25 are like i'm getting
weight yeah you're way too early for
that i'm out
you know you're literally the peak of
your life you're gay you're having
weight troubles already that's a whale
in the making and
third i want someone who's just like um
adaptable who like has values values are
big like i know a lot of women who do
their best to get it past me that like
they know how to say the right things
but i can see whether you really value
loyalty loyalty um whether you're
considerate whether you think about
other people
and whether you know how to like let a
man be a man or whether you're going to
be in my face making things difficult
would have to tolerate you in the future
sharp and to the point ladies
what about you
i just want to say that he made the same
face i made when you said the term real
man i just can't say there needs to be
serious pushback in the whole community
of relationship talk real man forget it
like stop saying that because because
who am i to tell you what constitutes a
real woman i'll get cancelled off the
internet by tomorrow it's not saying
what a real man is because
you don't
no
and you've got friends who are raising
sons with no dad around and women are
gonna
tell him when he grows up hearing a real
man
but you ain't telling your friends today
raw you're raising up this son with no
dad boy he's gonna struggle when he
grows up no one's telling their friends
that but you're quick to tell men
they're not real men
personally i'm looking for a woman
see i want a woman who rates me who i
want a woman who treats me like i'm the
best that she could have got okay yep
that's who that's who i want still you
want to feel needed yeah like i want to
feel i wouldn't because if i don't yeah
because and here's the thing i
understand that
a certain
caliber or
highly regarded woman what whatever may
not feel that way about me that's fine i
accept that but i understand that
there's levels i get it everyone is not
the same level but i also understand
that you know i need to be of a woman
who feels that way about me so if that
woman is a two out of 10 to the world
cool but that's how she feels about me
and then that lets me that gives me a
sense of confidence she makes you feel
like a team i'm gonna have the kind of
relationship that i want
you see we see forget all this stuff
like i want a man who makes me feel like
a 10 but he actually has to be a 10.
because the guys will guys will go down
in looks to go up in submissiveness what
massively yeah i don't i don't date
nines tens i didn't mention that
just because
at that point it's kind of like um some
guys are good enough
why should i why should i work so hard
to get a ferrari when a volkswagen golf
does exactly the same thing
is more reliable
this is the difference though how
intelligence like
rules the dating community because
there's some guys who are dumb enough to
chase these top girls and then they get
run they get run for everything they got
and they're crying i'm like dude because
she's just good looking that's all she's
got but on the flip side the thing is
what happens with that is that women see
guys giving those women attention
right and they think
guys want that it's like when guys go to
strip clubs all of the women in strip
clubs look like great well they see the
[ __ ] boys giving those guys attention
and they compete for the [ __ ] boys
yeah but it's like those women in the
strip clubs and those women on instagram
right who guys are giving attention
women general women see that and be like
oh is that what guys want no they just
wanted to like
say yes that looks great but that's not
gonna be his wife it's like i ask guys
all the time um bbl or natural but and
and they and they and what a lot of guys
would say for the night bbl but for long
term i'll take i'll take now i'll take
no butt over a bbl yeah because that
that's a wife and that's for fun
aesthetics is controlling a lot of if
you look at like guys you see i've
watched my brother scroll through
instagram right and that your blood it's
it's all it's programmed and you scroll
you like you scroll firefighter fire
scrolls
women don't know well not to my
knowledge i have a load of guys they
follow on instagram oh he's buffy's buff
so you see like the biological drivers
of sex driving men if you understand
that sex drives men you understand that
that's just the sex that in the
longevity of that
the woman who is the instagram model
with you know all of these eyelashes you
could fly to dubai on and nothing else
and then that's not going to be the wife
as you said it's a short-term solution
but it because certain women then allow
themselves to lack that intelligence to
see what's really going on here they
stay doing all of that nonsense for
years and years until they are no longer
eligible until they're a baby mom with
multiple baby fathers i aspire to never
be anyone's baby mother
like personally not like no
29 you know i'm in a relationship i
don't want to be someone's baby mom and
not you know it's i would aspire to be a
wife and you know this job
everyone wants lots of things but
whether you become a baby mom or not is
dependent on your values of course i
think i think no one says they do but i
can tell who's going to be one based on
the kind of stuff they say those girls
that want to attend i want this and that
i want to explore sexuality and have
money
baby mom
i think the money thing is a big thing
as well people are looking fine this
generation of of women are going to be
the first generation of women
the first generation of grandmas
the bbls
[Music]
no husband
face tattoos tattooed all over the place
mm-hmm like like this is going to be
that's good we're going to be the first
generation of grandmothers ass pics on
instagram yeah
like
what are you all doing
what are you all doing
do you not have families
do you not have families that are going
to see that
and this is kids to see that like
i had a whole i got a whole platform
right you will not catch me posting ass
pics on instagram and i can make money
off of that [ __ ] you guys are doing it
for free
i will say on that as far as we're
talking about aesthetics and whatnot um
it's not hard
i'm not trying to sound egotistical i
get male attention anybody can get male
or female attention regardless
regardless of anybody sexual attraction
five and above men no shortage of male
attention men can't get female attention
like women can nowhere near women women
are born with it men have to earn it
and
give yourself 10 years
it won't be easy yeah it kind of falls
off for women after 40 seconds
also the kind of men that give you
attention
finish what you're saying but i'm not
i'm just going to say like
what i struggle with is a man looking
beyond the physical
a little bit in a sense of understand
the substance behind it it's like a lot
of the times because you're quite
unquote
an attractive and i don't like to say
his face wheels really saying it an
attractive or desirable woman or male
they look at you and think okay you
might have the package or you might have
certain things but they might not be
willing to actually look beyond that and
think actually there's substance there
they can feel your energy you said do
you want sex at this time no sometimes i
want sex but there's substance and
they're not looking for substance in it
so you know what lane you've been put
into exactly if he's not willing to look
behind then he doesn't want to well and
the thing is like you are attractive so
you can get that like
the male attention but the problem is
when you have three kids they put you in
the for fun
and then by saying that by saying and
it's not
it's not disrespecting you know like
it's actually not i want to want women
to understand
when these things are said it's not a
disrespectfulness it's basically what
pearl's saying is she's trying to give
give you an insight into the male mind
she's trying to give you an insight into
the way in which males think she wants
you back
yeah take her back
it's like
men
like they think of they put women and
the thing is women do it too they put
men in categories do you know what i'm
saying like men put women in categories
and it's like
women need to all we're saying is we're
just exposing the cat we're showing you
the categories now ladies and the thing
is is that a lot of women will hear what
has been said and be like ah
and think they know better it's like but
men will consistently and continuously
tell you
and you will continuously and
consistently not listen
because they'll attack the messenger
when they can't attack the message the
truth is the truth but then it becomes
about then it becomes about you you know
oh well you're just saying that because
you and i was like listen listen the man
name who you you the man who you look up
to is more a man than me they think the
same thing i think they just ain't
telling you that because they're having
too much fun with well at least at least
if at least if you have the information
you can move accordingly
sweetheart
no you can't you can't take back having
children but if you're like you just
have to look at your options for the
next 10 years that's what i'm willing to
compromise but i'm not willing to
compromise a man that doesn't want to
look beyond the physical is what i'm
trying to say as well but most guys are
not going to tell you the truth because
they're trying to get into your knickers
but like you need to listen to the guys
that aren't trying to get into your
knickers yeah the guys that aren't
trying to get into your knickers are
going to tell you the truth the guys
that are going to they're trying to get
in think they'll tell you anything to
get in there do you understand yeah but
you did say that you valued sex as the
biggest thing and that was like what you
were doing right now
at a time like like right
i know do you know what maybe i was just
being a bit too hasty in it let's just
be real no you're being honest doesn't
it
let's
right can i just try and explain a
little bit okay
what i'm saying is that
everything else is of value to me a man
being um
sure of himself being confident you know
having a certain level of um
family values and like everything is
everywhere
if that was true when we i asked you the
question would you would you pick the
finances
and we could go back and cut it
to where to where i said to where i said
no no no we're not in the business of
changing men these are the options
and
she and she said
that she would pick the guy with the job
and the financial stability she did say
she did say she would cheat on him so i
don't know if that's better um
i'm very loyal which is which is good
but i think you might value the wrong
things because the bum isn't going to
make a good step dad
i understand the feminine urge to try
and like twist it into something that
sounds somewhat reasonable but i think
really really you know that that's what
you actually want because at the moment
it means she's lost faith it's not just
sex maybe she's lost and why did you say
sex first and foremost
was that sex was the um
the the driving uh driving force in that
situation in that comment right in that
question however i also want somebody i
could enjoy life like everything i'm
working hard for right now in life i
want somebody i can ultimately enjoy it
with
that includes great sex
i know exactly the guy men lead with one
team
before
you've got three children
i know exactly the dude
take her back
she's sorry she didn't mean what she
said it's not too late
[Laughter]
adonis 1909 her feet are in the pit now
um french biz lady in the red you keep
talking about substance but you are
judging but you can't be the one judging
said substance you don't judge your
value men do wendell coven make the
ladies bring facts to their points 50
super chat sarah dropping bombs
um 90 free to pay um pearl next time
your guests say not all please make them
put five dollars in a jar they have to
stop
neon moses lady and the green are you
married he's interested am i married yes
no
you could be according to this guy
okay punisher um if you want a wife to
if you want to be a wife and a happy
marriage you only need one skill to make
the man you want feel like your support
means he can attain for your family the
things you both want for it 90 free toe
pain lady in green
men build up you you cute good can't
read i'll teach you women start from the
top you all move in
um
whoa
okay 90 free toe pet oh and i read those
already earlier okay
manny f
pearl you should ask the ladies if they
if any of their male friends would smash
them and test them with the smash text
just human pearl have ish signal your
intermission so you can read the super
chats french biz lady inbred it's not
that the man you go for lack masculinity
if you aren't in your feminine it's it's
that your starting point as a female is
too high wendell coven will the ladies
in the pink and the red make changes
after listening to what men want or will
they stay the same vincent docile fat
chicks deserve love just not from me
just human just human masculine men
operate with honor and discipline if he
makes an agreement he will stand by it
monogamy included masculine men have
control over impulses it's feminine men
that will cheat no honor mt pearl would
you say that women leave a man for the
same reasons they were attracted to him
aggressive she turns she turns him
emotionally money no money
tmac 1979 one of the best conversations
ever on the show the bros are bringing
it over analyzed men don't want to come
home to another boss energy after
dealing with boss energy in the office
kefir hunter by thirty fifty percent of
your daily dating pool is gone ninety
percent of your eggs are gone geriatric
pregnancy starts at 35 and 36 then add
in the disney princess mentality no
father households overweight and
overbeast overweight obese and
argumentative me mike shorty and the
green has been dashing and hinting at a
assortative mating if she opens a little
bit her mind a little bit to pearl's
knowledge she stands a chance at finding
a decent man the other two are too far
gone mr t one thousand if kevin samuels
had a soundboard he'd be hitting all the
buttons right now i and mack from 15 to
30 guys get rejected over and over again
by women life and later in life the
tables turn and women have no experience
of what rejection feels like and they
feel entitled reality does not care just
human women in pink a man you vetted
wants to discipline your child and you
don't agree with how why do you did you
default to an image of a man abusing
them why would you choose a guide who
abuses your children do you not trust
men do you not trust their judgment
clockwise prolly please include links to
the original videos when you post clips
of the episode they'll be roasting me
sometimes utmost give any man on this
earth two million dollars a mansion a
lamborghini and a blue check on
instagram i promise none of the 32 year
old none of them would choose a 32 year
old woman with three kids wait to wake
the hell up
balisman men are definitely looking for
a woman to
too old to give him children but has
another man's kids for him to raise the
uk economist please ask your guest in
pink if she was getting professional
therapy before she decided to end her
relationship
right up right up if you didn't
sacrifice you broke the home up and
disrupted your kid's life because of
your selfish needs dragon stallion one
zero zero one woman in pink do you not
know the meaning of the word narcissist
bet your pick is right there in the
dictionary under the explanation kyle
2020 here's an equally absurd question
with the same answer are you intimidated
by a submission virginal man
mt would you pay would you pay with your
own money half of a man's child from his
baby mama and still have little or no
say for how to raise the child knowing
he could leave you and never talk to the
child again me mike you're debating a
logical argument with an emotional
person she keeps saying if i feel like
just pass on her
she ain't
locking down a high value man pearl your
fire the uk economist for the most
quality men who have assets and wealth
why would he pass his success to another
bloodline that does not care carry his
biological lineage
chris to the lady in the middle ma'am
i'm a man man who makes 100k a month and
trust me women like you don't intimidate
me using the word intimidate is how
women like you cope with the fact that
men don't deal with you and only viewed
you as a side chick
swell city does she look or read at
super super chats elia when dating
single women with children does it make
oh they did the widow i'm going to go
back to the bottom
so great show your streams are the your
best streams are with pearls one is a
little bit more masculine and one is a
little more feminine gus one out of 200
people in the world is related to gangas
khan swell city a man only cheats when
he commits adultery by laying with
another man's wife dragon stallion one
zero zero one uh that was the sexual
needs one um december zero eight eight
one men want women want to be wanted men
want to be needed
dragon stallion one zero zero one sorry
but no man wants to spend their
resources on raising another man's kids
okay
i think that was all of them unless
there was some that refreshed in the
chat but
why don't we go around um everyone give
any final thoughts that you have and
tell people where they can find you
i'm tired
firstly you can find me at d golly on
all the socials d-e-e-g-u-w-l-y
i'm on the socials and my takeaway
my takeaway would be that if
women
only dated men
who they had the utmost respect for and
believed that this was the best they
could get
and stayed away from everybody else
yeah then we'd have
women who'd be forced to face their
singledom because they can't actually
get the men who don't want to level off
and then we'd have less resentment and
contempt because there'd be less women
with men who they think they're better
than so stay available for the men who
you think are on your level and if
you're not on their level you'll have
nobody
[Music]
uh key takeaways so uh you can find me
on
instagram lola
underscore rose blanc which is b l a and
c
um thank you for having me guys on the
show it's very interesting uh key
takeaways i think is um as dee just
mentioned looking at
for both men and women where you are in
your lane and what do you actually value
in a relationship or are you looking for
a situationship were you looking for
simple sexual satisfaction so you need
to sometimes separate what is it you
actually want so once you've established
what you want you are then free to go
forward and find that this all there's a
lot of confusion between what people
want in the long term versus what looks
good now because what something that
looks good now like you go down the
stains where you should buy a mango
looks good
you leave it on the side it doesn't look
good the next day there's no longevity
you know so you use what you want now
and what you want in the future once
you've assessed that you can decide how
how are you going to go about finding
that and also one thing we didn't really
touch upon is where you find these
people so it's another episode but for
example i don't online date because
looking for an argos catalogue of people
no interest in doing that so where are
you actually finding these people you're
looking in nightclubs for a husband or a
wife doesn't make sense so actually
looking at what do you value and where
will you actually find those people that
you value if you're looking for sex
maybe looking online is the best way to
do it if you're looking for a husband or
wife
perhaps looking more at what your
interests are and then go to the library
if you like someone your university you
know
that would be my takeaways um yeah and
also the internet's a very savage place
people are entitled to you know let them
speak their truth respectfully unless
yeah that's that's my other takeaway
thank you
okay so uh on inside it's at reams
underscore xox and our podcast is at
noisex banter thank you so much to pearl
and to sarah for
this experience it has been great um
what have i taken away from this or my
little two-part i'm definitely i'd like
to say thank you to the guys as well
because you guys have been great i've
learned a lot i love to listen to men i
know you lot might not think that but i
actually do because i learn um when i do
that but um
yeah just keep
don't sell
that's what i'm gonna throw out there
don't settle down
if you want to do what you want you know
what i mean but i think um definitely
you know
just just
be realistic with the
the line that you're holding for
yourself but again thank you so much
because the guys here have been great
yeah in our second that roomsy um so
guys you can find me on instagram
glamchatnads and also noisex banter for
our podcast um
and what i've taken away from this
experience has been quite enlightening
so i am thank you oh we aim to please
yeah it's very enlightening um what i've
taken away is that
men will tell you or know the value that
you have to them and you cannot force
upon what values you feel you have
in order to please that man or gain that
man
um but then also i always stand by the
fact that just stay in your lane and be
willing to compromise when you know you
might not tick all the boxes
so
but definitely always be yourself
because there's always going to be
somebody out there that will accept you
for everything you have and everything
you are
not always like like it's like one out
of one out of three men don't reproduce
so
just just keep i love this
keep hope alive
and 50 of women are single and childless
so that's not that's not like a lot of
you will die alone so continue
she's not wrong
anyways population control bro yeah 7.6
um my name's alexander
and you can catch me on instagram at
santochiku-s-u-n-t-o-c-h-u-k-w-u
uh my take away from this is guys
this is what women actually think some
of you might out here getting frustrated
at this market
these are the views this is what you're
competing with so i would say just
listen adjust adjust your views adjust
the way you're approaching things adjust
the kind of information you're using to
inform your decisions and act
accordingly and i guarantee you can find
the woman you want out there there are
women who align with your values um you
know you just have to be clever about it
um and never if you talk to women long
enough they'll tell you what they
actually really think so just be patient
and um
keep hustling
um you can find me on instagram k i i
dot k i i
i think one thing i'll just say is that
honesty is probably the best thing you
could give
anyone
especially yourself yep and that is what
i'm gonna
that's what i'm gonna end on
well
this has been the gray area once again
um i've really enjoyed this uh this talk
um i feel like people have learned
i feel like uh
we've given a lot of information right
bro and um i think the audience were
edified
in this in the in this podcast
we
shall be back next tuesday with the grey
area pearl is always here as you guys
already know
um
and like i said if you haven't
yeah subscribed and you've watched two
or more of our videos then we got beef
beef i'll take it away all right guys as
you know we are saving for a camera so i
appreciate all of the donations that we
got today let us get let's get ish a
camera you already know just get it
um guys on the way out please like the
video a like is free don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell and sign up for our
memberships our chat is lit so sign up
for the memberships and you get
exclusive behind-the-scenes content we
have two vlogs up that are
ish lost a bet and if you want to see
what happened sign up
fun fun fun
okay guys thank you for watching we will
talk to you next time